Hallo, hier ist Chaos Radio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 155 und mein Name ist wie gewohnt Tim Pritlove. Hier war eine Weile Produktionspause. Ich hatte so viele Sendungen in einem Blog abgeliefert, dass ich ganz ausgelastet damit war die überhaupt erst mal zu veröffentlichen. Aber jetzt gibt es wieder Frischfleisch und mal wieder auch ein paar Themen, die, wie es immer so ist, schon lange ihrer Veröffentlichung geharrt haben. So soll es auch heute sein und ich begrüße als Gast Thorsten Holz. Hallo. Du bist, was bist du denn? Du bist eigentlich, darf man Security-Experte sagen oder ist das so? Es gibt doch bestimmt ein paar goldene Formulierungen, oder?
Was verwendest du so? Na ja, es ist schwierig, wenn man sich selber so redet. Ich interessiere mich für Sicherheit, mache das gerne, aber als Hobby, als Beruf, also.
Du steckst da schon drin. Ich lasse den Expert mal weg. Du bist Security Nerd und beschäftigst dich auf jeden Fall schon einige Zeit damit. Hast ja auch den einen oder anderen Vortrag auf den Kongress gehalten.
Klar, komm gerne dorthin.
Da gibt es auch immer so Schwerpunkte bei dir und einen dieser Schwerpunkte wollte ich heute mal aufgreifen. Nämlich so dieses Phänomen der Botnetze, oder sagen wir mal ein bisschen allgemeiner gefasst, so dieses Phänomen, dass doch ein Großteil der Computerlandschaft, die da draußen so installiert ist und vor sich hin brummt und Strom frisst, irgendwie nicht wirklich eine Burg ist, sondern Käse da rumliegt, rumgammelt, zerfressen wird und da die Ameisen durchkrabbeln und man sich irgendwie fragt, wohin das eigentlich alles noch führen soll bzw. wohin das überhaupt schon alles geführt hat. Aber bevor wir vielleicht darauf gehen, vielleicht noch mal so ein bisschen zu dir. Du hast es ja schon angedeutet, du machst es beruflich. Das war schon mal dein Hobby. Was ist denn so dein Werdegang? Bist du auch so ein C64-Kind?
Na ja, ich habe den Amiga 500 gehabt. Die anderen, leider damals, wo die Leute mit dem zusammengehangen haben. Damals waren alles Amigaleute. Das war ja schon ein Computer relativ lange. Ich habe dann irgendwann Informatik studiert, also so der klassische Werdegang. Das ist aber nicht abgebrochen.
Man kann ja trotzdem was werden.
Ich war dann eine Zeit lang an der Uni Mannheim, habe dann auch promoviert. Dann an der TU Wien habe ich jetzt die letzten neun Monate gearbeitet. Und dann seit letztem Monat, also jetzt seit dem April, bin ich an der Ruhr-Uni in Bochum als Junior-Professor tätig. Also überhaupt nicht abgebrochen, sondern eher so.
Junior-Professor für was? Also was ist das?
Der offizielle Titel heißt Embedded Malware.
Na gut, also das geht schon.
Das geht schon über die Security, genau. Ob das jetzt Embedded, also ich stemme ja mit eher so die Smartphones eher vor. Ob wir dann irgendwann Malware für Kühlschränke machen, müssen wir mal schauen.
Achso, Embedded Malware im Sinne von Malware auf Embedded Devices, also auf kleinen, vielleicht auch portablen Geräten.
auch wo es einfach irgendwo eingebaut ist. Also woher gibt es beispielsweise einige Gruppen, die sich mit Sicherheit von Autos beschäftigen. Dort gab es auch letztes Jahr auf dem Kongress einen Vortrag, dass sie Keylock gebrochen haben, dass so der Funkstandard für Garagentore zu öffnen, oder auch für Autos zu öffnen.
Keylock im Sinne von Lockschloss.
Genau, ja. Und prinzipiell, wie kann man auch Autos angreifen und sonstige Dinge. Das ist eben auch ein interessantes Thema eigentlich.
Keylock, Garagentore.
Genau, also der Funkstandard ist dann gebrochen und dann einfach die Box gehabt, wo man einfach drauf drückt und dann geht das Tor auf oder geht das Auto auf. Im Idealfall.
Ach so, das ist dann auch noch derselbe Standard, der auch noch für die Autos verwendet wird?
Ja, es gibt so ein paar Unterschiede, aber prinzipiell kann man in dem Bereich auch was machen.
Wie sicher sind denn so die Autoverschlüsselungen?
Naja, so weit ich weiß, kommt man da schon ziemlich weit, wenn man böse ist.
Oh, du hast gelächelt. Das ist furchtbar.
Schauen wir uns gerade so ein bisschen was an. Ist eben teilweise schwierig, weil die sind ja so eingebettete Geräte, wo man dann erst mal rausfinden muss, was für ein Krypto-Algorithmus machen die dann, und dann gibt es in Bochum auch viele Leute, die so Krypto machen, gerade auch die ganzen Schiffren brechen wollen. Mal schauen, wo wir dahin kommen.
Eigentlich gibt es noch nicht so richtig, oder gibt es, mal so rumgefragt, gibt es irgendwie schon einen Bereich der Krypto, wo sich irgendwie ein größerer Teil dieser Security-Szene beruhigt fühlt, also nach dem Motto, wenn man diese Art Krypto zur Anwendung bringt, naja, dann muss man jetzt nicht unbedingt so früh aufstehen. Oder ist das irgendwie alles so eine wabernde Masse und man mag sich gar nicht mehr frei bewegen?
Also ich finde, das ist teilweise so Blackmagic, ziemlich Voodoo-lastig. Also ich hatte jetzt vor zwei Tagen noch einen Vortrag in dem Bereich gehört, wo es dann das einmal ging, ja wir haben jetzt hier unseren Krypto-Algorithmus, dann nehme ich da einen Baustein weg, dann wird das besser, da tue ich den Baustein hinzu, dadurch wird es schlechter. Und ich glaube, die wissen teilweise selber nicht, wie man da so ein, was am besten baut und ich denke, die Algorithmen, die wir haben, sind noch sicher, aber es ist die Frage, wo wir in zehn Jahren stehen.
Also auf jeden Fall ist es so ein Moving Target, dass es irgendwie ein Prozess ist, aber sehr schön ist, also Sicherheit ist kein Zustand, sondern ein Prozess. Und da muss man dann wahrscheinlich wirklich einfach dranbleiben. Das heißt aber auch, dass alles, was heute in Gerät gegossen wird, unter Umständen, wie du sagst, in zehn Jahren, einfach gar nicht mehr sicher ist.
Ja genau, das kann natürlich sein. Das sehen wir im Moment, denke ich mal, im Bereich GSM ganz gut. Die Systeme, die jetzt irgendwie 15, 20 vielleicht noch länger einfach sicher waren, wo jetzt in den letzten zwei, drei Jahren sich ja sehr viel getan hat, dass ich jetzt meine eigene GSM-Basistation betreiben kann, und ein Update von der Basistation ist eben nicht so einfach. Ich denke, da werden wir in den nächsten zwei, drei Jahren auch noch interessante Entwicklungen sehen. Gerade GSM ist ja auch ein super spannendes Thema.
Ja, das war ja hier auch schon ein paar mal zu Gast mit Harald Welte, der da auch ganz kundig ist, weil er ja auch seinen eigenen GSM-Stack da gerade schreibt. Das war ja auch schon mal das Thema. Open BSC, so ein Titel der Sendung, worum vielleicht viele gar nicht wussten, worum es eigentlich geht, CRI120. Kann man sich den Zusammenhang mal anhören. Ich hatte auch schon noch mal was anderes. Ich hatte auch noch mal dieses GSM-Hacking, es ging noch ein bisschen älter, CRI56. Wenn man sich das anhört, dann wird einem schon schnell klar, warum das auch alles noch sehr wackelig ist. Da ist natürlich wirklich eine Menge in Selizium gegossen. Genau. Ich meine, wie schwierig das ist, für Telefone Updates zu kriegen, das sieht man ja schon allein bei den normalen Konsumer-Handys so. Eigentlich wird fast überhaupt nichts aktualisiert, was zum Zeitpunkt der Drucklegung nicht schon halbwegs sicher ist oder zumindest so featurearm ist, dass so viel passieren kann. Das ist dann halt echt schon ein Problem.
Ja, und wenn es dann eben noch mehr eingebettete Systeme ist, das wird ja immer schwieriger. Entweder den Fernseher, den ich jetzt über DVB-T updaten kann oder so.
Aber so das klassische Feld sind natürlich die desktops. Also die großen Maschinen, die PCs, die Macs, was auch immer, die halt so auf den Schreibtischen stehen. Egal, ob es jetzt Laptops sind oder große, schwere... Ich weiß gar nicht, warum diese Dinger immer noch so groß sein müssen. Das verstehe ich irgendwie überhaupt nicht. Was ist eigentlich passiert? Was ist denn so dein Gefühl? Seit wann gibt es eigentlich dieses Bewusstsein für Sicherheit? Also im Sinne von, dass es wirklich so eine Security-Szene gibt, die sich da wirklich darum kümmert, eine Mindestanzahl an Firmen, die so eine Brancheninfrastruktur darstellen. Das ist ja auch alles so alt, nicht?
Nee, ich gar nicht. Obwohl hat sich in letzter Zeit echt viel getan. Wenn ich jetzt denke, die ersten Computerwürmer, damals Morris 88, seitdem hat das Bewusstsein an sich relativ groß geworden. Als man zum ersten Mal Morriswurm gesehen hat, da gibt es ja diese Schwachstellen, wenn Programme sich autonom weiterverbreiten können.
Das war damals die Sun-Computer und so ein Send-Mail-basiertes Gewohne.
Ich glaube, es hat 3-4 Exploits benutzt, unter anderem Send-Mail und noch ein paar andere Schwachstellen ausgenutzt. Ein signifikanten Prozentsatz aller PCs im damaligen Internet.
Ich glaube, es waren nur Sun-Rechner, die damals betroffen waren.
Ja, aber da hingen eben viele damals an.
Ja klar, das war extrem verbreitet.
Ich denke, seitdem ist einfach so das Bewusstsein relativ stark gewachsen. Und dann gab es natürlich auch in der Community wirklich so eine Sturm- und Trankphase, wo viel gemacht wurde. Einfach neue Exploit-Techniken entwickelt wurden. Und dann jetzt in den letzten zehn Jahren wurde das ja auch immer kommerzialisierter. Das wir jetzt viele Firmen haben in dem Bereich. Die ganzen Pentester oder die ganzen AV-Firmen, die ja Billionen oder Milliarden Umsätze machen, das ist ja schon, denke ich mal, etwas, wo wir viel gesehen haben in letzter Zeit. Und auch die Community an sich ist ja gewachsen. Wenn man sich allein so den Kongress anschaut, wie viele Tausend Leute da mittlerweile rumlaufen. Ich glaube, so das Security-Bewusstsein an sich ist gewachsen und viele Leute finden das einfach spannend. Das sehen wir auch an den Studis bei uns. Wenn wir dann so ein Praktikum anbieten in dem Bereich, wird einfach sehr gut angenommen von den Studis, weil die es einfach spannend finden, wie kann ich jetzt System angreifen oder System absichern und so. So der Spieltrieb wird ja auch ein bisschen gefördert bei sowas.
Aber gut, also dieser Morris Wurm, der stand sozusagen am Anfang. Aber das war ja nur wirklich sehr lange her. Wann war das? Das war doch Ende der 80er Jahre. Damals hat ja eigentlich noch überhaupt niemand das Internet als solches wahrgenommen. Das gab es zwar und als darüber berichtet wurde, so naja, okay, irgendwelche Datennetze in den USA, so richtig verstanden hat das ja die Öffentlichkeit nun mal schon gar nicht.
Wer hatte denn schon damals einen PC, der irgendwie...
Genau, also ich denke, dass das Internet war ja überhaupt frühestens 95, 96, bei den meisten Leuten, bei den meisten Leuten wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal, da kam das überhaupt erst mal auf. Und ich denke erst seit 2000 hat eigentlich die Gesellschaft wirklich begriffen, dass es das Internet jetzt einfach gibt und dass es nicht wieder weggeht.
Ich denke auch, also, ich sage nur so etwas wie UNIS98, das ja noch nicht mal richtig vernetzt werden konnte. Ich denke dann UNISFORD 1000 war so ein großer Schritt. Und dann hatten wir ja kurz danach ja so Würmer wie I Love You oder Code Red, die es wirklich auch nicht Schlagzeilen geschafft haben. Gerade I Love You, der sich einfach nur per Mail weiterverbreitet hat und einfach auch großen Schaden angerichtet hat damals. Ich glaube, das war so eins der Events, wo auch in der Mainstream-Presse mal über solche Sachen berichtet wurde und die Leute quasi gelernt haben, was so schiefgehen kann und so.
Wie ist denn so, vielleicht stellen wir das nochmal ganz an den Anfang, wie ist denn so deine Definition, weil das immer so verwirrend ist, Viren und Würmer? Also was oder überhaupt was für Kategorien von Malware unterscheidest du so grob, wenn du Dinge beschreibst?
Es gibt viele Kategorien und vieles ist auch so ein Mischmasch aus einigen Viren. Sagen wir so was wie die klassischen Viren. Das wäre eher, dass eine ausführbare Datei wird infiziert. Entweder man hängt hinten noch was Code an oder vorne hängt man ein bisschen Code davor. Das ist einfach so, dass eine ausführbare Datei wirklich befallen wird und dann der Virus sich so weiter verbreitet. Wenn diese Datei ausgeführt wird, wird der Virus aktiv und versucht einfach andere Dateien zu infizieren. Die Würmer im Gegensatz dazu sind eher so sich selbst weiterverbreitende Programme. Also die können von einem Rechner auf den anderen übertragen werden. Entweder indem sie beispielsweise Schwachstellen ausnutzen, indem sie sich an eine Mail dranhängen oder Mails rausschicken oder einfach Passwörter raten von anderen Maschinen. Aber Hauptsache, die können sich von einem Rechner auf den anderen weiterverbreiten. Dann sehr eng damit verwandt sind eben die Bots. Ein Bot ist eigentlich auch Software, die sich automatisch weiterverbreiten kann. Und der interessante Aspekt dort ist, dass es eben noch den Angreifer gibt, der einfach Befehle ausführen kann. Und die Bots reagieren dann darauf und führen diesen Befehl dann aus. So quasi die Weiterentwicklung. Weil mit Würmern, wenn die sich nur automatisch weiterverbreiten, hat der Angreifer wenig davon. Er kann zwar Schaden anrichten, aber...
Beziehungsweise er muss die ganze, alles, seine ganzen Ziele von vornherein schon in diesen Code rein tun.
Richtig, ja. Und eigentlich will der Angreifer ja irgendwie flexible Kontrolle haben, dass er mal Spam-Mails rausschicken kann, mal irgendwelche Angriffe ausführen kann, mal Informationen stehlen kann. Deshalb will er ja eigentlich so einen flexiblen Kontrollmechanismus haben. Und das sind dann eben die Bots. Die haben dann eben noch so den Rückkanal zum Angreifer und können Befehle ausführen. Dann gibt es natürlich noch sowas wie Trojana oder Trojanische Pferde. Einfach ganz normale Programme, die eben noch eine Funktionalität haben, die was anderes macht. Die beispielsweise noch eine Backdoor öffnet oder die noch neben dem ganz normalen Programm eben noch Daten stiegelt und dann zurück zum Angreifer schickt. Was gibt es denn noch? Viren, Bots, Würmer, Trojana. Dann gibt es noch Keylogger als klassische Art von Schad-Software, die einfach irgendwie mitschneidet, was der Benutzer macht. Passwörterstil, den dann zurück schickt zum Angreifer. Und was gibt es denn noch? Wie gesagt, viele Mich-Formen. Also was weiß ich, ein Bot Keylogging machen kann.
Ja klar, das sind typische Grundsachen. So ein Bot hat von daher natürlich am meisten Power. So konzeptionell, weil er ja irgendwie seine Instruktion erst zu dem Zeitpunkt bekommt, wo er sich schön eingerichtet hat.
Genau, und dass der Angreifer eben auch flexibel reagieren kann. Wenn jetzt eben heute was ich nur Spam rausschicken will, mach das einfach. Und wenn dann morgen irgendwie so ein Distributed Final-of-Service-Angriff machen will, so ein DDoS-Angriff, mach das eben morgen einfach DDoSen.
Aber wären jetzt alle Systeme wunderbar sicher und es gäbe keine Fehler, die man ausnutzen kann, dann würde ja gar nichts passieren. Tatsächlich ist es aber nicht so, sondern Fehler treten halt auf und viele Fehler sind dann doch immer wieder so fatal, dass dadurch eben größere Scheunentheore aufgerissen werden. Was ist denn so das Hauptziel eigentlich? Also wie hat sich das denn...
Also ich denke, da haben wir in den letzten Jahren auch relativ viele Änderungen gesehen. Während so in den 2000, 2004 so was in dem Bereich relativ viel noch so for fun war, einfach die Angreifer haben einfach nur anfangs einen Spaß gehabt, einfach möglichst viele Rechner zu infizieren und einfach Chaos zu machen. Ich glaube, das war damals noch so...
Der will nur spielen.
Genau, ja. Und ich denke, so 2004, 2005...
Du bist jetzt schon im Prinzip schon bei den Bots.
Genau. Ja, oder generell auch.
Aber ich meine, das Problem ist doch noch viel älter als das, als 2000. Ich meine, auch so Sicherheitsangriffe, Viren gab es auch schon vorher.
Ja, schon. Aber ich denke, da war vieles eben auch wirklich vor Fun. Also viele Leute haben einfach so aus Spaß versucht, Computer zu ownen und so was. Klar, es gab auch die gezielten Angriffe auf...
Ja, ich meine, da gab es, aber es gab ja auch schon relativ populäre, was nicht, dieser I Love You-Virus, den du vorhin genannt hast. Wann war das?
Ich würde sagen so 2002. Ich denke auch Code Red und sowas. Code Red war, glaube ich, auch... War I Love You 2000?
Auf der Wikipedia gibt es eine gute Übersicht. Mai 2000 war der I Love You-Virus.
Code Red 2002, ja.
Mal gucken, was haben wir denn hier? Sollen wir erstmal wissen, wie die sich schreiben.
Wikipedia hat eine relativ gute Übersicht eigentlich.
So die Geschichte. Der was Malware?
Genau, die Übersicht ist eine Zeitleiste, die eigentlich ganz nett gemacht ist.
Lass mal finden. Malware, Spyware.
Ah, Spyware natürlich auch.
Da fallen ja die Keylogger drunter, oder?
Oder eben auch Programme, die Screenshots machen oder Mikro anmachen, Kamera anmachen, sonstige Sachen.
Ich finde jetzt diese Liste gerade nicht, aber gibt es bestimmt.
Backorifice war natürlich auch noch so ein großer Vertreter.
Oh ja, stimmt.
Das war so 1999, so 2000, würde ich sagen.
Wobei, das war ja, also Backorifice, das war ja im Prinzip so mit Ansage. Das war ja jetzt nicht so ein geheimes Ding, was sich verbreitet hat, sondern das war so Software zum Runterladen. Von Kaltos in Dead Cow, ja als Hackergruppe auch bekannt. Was, so aus deiner Sicht, was war da die Motivation? Ich meine, da ging es doch irgendwie gegen Windows.
Ja, ich denke, die wollten einfach mal demonstrieren, was kann man machen, wenn man böse ist oder so. Man muss ja einfach nur dem Opfer das Programm irgendwie unterschieben. Das war ja dann nicht wirklich mehr sichtbar, wenn das auf dem System lief. Und das war ja dann so diese Remote Access Trojans, das so eben wirklich mit irgendeinem normalen Programm kombinierst du Backorifice. Und dann schickst du das zum Opfer, der führt es aus. Und dann hast du eben auch diesen Rückkanal, wo du eben sehen kannst, was das Opfer gerade macht. Oder eben auch eher so Spaßfaktoren, dass du einfach mal das CD-Laufwerk aufmachst oder so. Ich glaube, das war wirklich so Proof of Concept, einfach zu zeigen, was kann man machen.
Also du meinst, 90er Jahre waren im Prinzip sozusagen noch ein bisschen paradiesische Zustände. Es gab den einen oder anderen Versuch, böse zu sein. Aber dass das Ganze wirklich so einen kriminellen Drive bekommen hat und sich zunehmend proffesionalisiert hat, das war quasi ab 2000, also vor 10 Jahren sozusagen zu verzeichnen.
Ja, ich würde sagen, viele Techniken, gerade im Bereich so Buffer-Overflows oder ganzen Heap-Overflows und so, das wurde ja erst so Ende der 90er entwickelt. Und dann Frac hatte damals ja so seine Hochzeit oder auch so viele Gruppen wie THC oder so, die auch in der Zeit quasi super aktiv waren. Und so ab 2000, denke ich mal, war er so der Wendepunkt mit vielleicht wirklich I Love You und so. Das sind großen Vorfällen.
Was ist dann passiert? Also ich meine, das war dann quasi auch so einerseits der Geburt einer Computer-Security-Branche und parallel eben auch den entsprechenden Bösewichtern auf der anderen Seite.
Ja, genau. Und dann hat sich das ja, wie gesagt, am Anfang eben dieses Ganze vor Fun und dann mehr und mehr wirklich for profit. Dass einfach die Leute gemerkt haben, hey, über diese Angriffe können wir auch wirklich Kohle machen.
Wie machen die denn die Kohle?
Verschiedene Möglichkeiten. Entweder einfach von den komfrontierten Maschinen auf Spam verschicken und dann quasi spamming as a service, dass man einfach, sagen wir, 10 Millionen oder 100 Millionen Femme jetzt rausschickt.
Werbedienstleistung.
Ja, so ein bisschen. Dann so DDoS ist natürlich auch so eine Art Sport, einfach, dass die Kiddies sich gegenseitig DDoSen. Wer kann mehr machen? Aber kann man natürlich auch so Erpressungsversuche machen und so, wo sonstige Sachen, gegen, was ich online Casinos war, so eine Zeit lang ein bisschen hip. Dann das Stehlen von Informationen von den Maschinen, ist natürlich auch lukrativ, dass man Passwörter sich nimmt oder die Zugangsdaten für so irgendwas oder auch Dokumente stielt. Ja und sonst einfach die komfrontierten Maschinen als Proxy benutzt, um darüber dann zu tunneln oder sowas. Also die Angreifer haben da verschiedene Möglichkeiten, würde ich sagen.
So und das heißt, im Prinzip kann man feststellen, dass eben diese ganzen einzelnen Techniken, wie sich jetzt Software einerseits in ein System hineinbringt und wie es sich dann eben verhält in zunehmendem Maße so kombiniert wurden, dass eben diese Botnetze draus wurden, dass man quasi gesagt hat, okay, alles klar, warum sollen wir nur einmal in den Rechner reingehen? Wir können doch anfangen, uns dort richtig schön einzunisten, dort einfach präsent zu sein. Und dann haben wir da sozusagen unsere digitalen Schläfer, die nur darauf warten, von außen aktiviert zu werden, um dann für was auch immer herangezogen zu werden.
So ein anderer Aspekt, der natürlich auch so ein bisschen reinspielt, sind so diese IRC-Wars, die es damals gab. Also ein Bot an sich ist ja an sich nicht böse. Gerade wenn man im IRC-Netz damals unterwegs war, hat man Bots ja eigentlich gekannt, quasi innerhalb von verschiedenen Channels. Dass einfach die Bots irgendwelche Services angeboten haben. Sei es vielleicht nur so ein kleines Spiel oder irgendwie so ein Authentication gemacht haben und sonstige Sachen.
Benutzt man da wirklich dieselbe Art? Okay, man nennt sie auch Bots. Also insofern muss man vielleicht noch unterscheiden zwischen Bots, die ja dafür gedacht sind, einem irgendwie eine Dienstleistung zu erbringen, die völlig okay ist. Also wie zum Beispiel IRC, aber die gibt es ja auch in anderen Kommunikationsnetzen. IRC sind sehr sicherlich am populärsten. Und wenn es nur so was ist wie, keine Ahnung, hier ein Chaos-Radio-Chat reingeht, dann gibt es dann irgendwie auch so ein paar Bots, die haben dann auch schnell mal irgendwie so die wichtigen Webseiten, die man wissen muss, Aufzeichnungen etc. rausspucken. So war es.
Genau. es gibt wirklich Botnetze, die auch so gebaut sind. Also die Angreifer konfrontieren die Maschine, laden dann wirklich so einen IRC-Client, Merck als Standardfall, einfach hoch auf diese Maschine, sorgen dann dafür, dass das Programm nicht sichtbar ist. Der verbindet sich zum IRC-Netz und hat eben noch die Funktionalität, dass er auf Befehle reagiert.
Verstehe, du meinst, dass er sich sozusagen in das IRC-Netz einklingt, um von dort seine Befehle entgegenzunehmen.
Genau, ja. Und die benutzen wirklich Standard-IRC-Clients teilweise, die einfach ein bisschen gepatcht sind, ein bisschen aufgebohrt, dass sie eben auch wirklich Befehle nutzen. Das waren so die ersten paar Generationen von Botnetzen. Die haben einfach typischerweise IRC als Kommunikationsprotokoll benutzt. Also auf der konformierten Maschine wurde ein kleines Programm installiert, was sich dann zu einem IRC-Server verbunden hat. Dann in einen bestimmten Channel reingeht, der eventuell noch per Passwort geschützt ist. Und dort sitzt dann auch der Angreifer. Und der sieht dann eben die Bots, wie die die ganze Zeit joinen. Also in den Channel reinkommen, wie die da rausgehen. Und wenn er dann Befehle eingibt, reagieren die Bots drauf und machen eben etwas, beispielsweise, dass sie Spam-Mails rausschicken oder anfangen mitzuloggen.
Die man dann auch über diesen Kanal hineinidiziert.
Genau, ja. Der Angreifer joint auch den Kanal und muss sich dann typischerweise autorisieren, dass er irgendwie ein Passwort eingibt und dass die Bots dann auf seine Befehle hören. Und dann kann er das einfach machen. Und IRC war, sagen wir, bis vor drei, vier Jahren oder vielleicht zwei, drei Jahren auch das Standard-Protokoll, was eigentlich fast alle benutzt haben. 80, 90 Prozent der Botnetze benutzen einfach IRC. Weil das einfach hat sich so historisch entwickelt, würde ich sagen.
Ja, der hat ja auch dann gleich diverse Vorteile. Man muss nicht direkt mit diesen Maschinen verbunden sein, sondern man kann das quasi indirekt über dieses IRC-Netzwerk tun. Die können ja auch an ganz anderen Servern eingeloggt sein, als man selbst und die Server tauschen dann quasi die Daten untereinander aus. So ein IRC-Netzwerk, so dass man eben nicht auch sofort tracebar wäre jetzt von den eigentlichen Verbindungen her.
Genau, und die haben teilweise wirklich auch, die existieren IRC-Netz einfach benutzt, also was sich Andernet oder die ganzen großen Netze oder in einigen Channels waren einfach die Bots. Das war damals definitiv noch ein Problem. Mittlerweile haben die es gut unter Kontrolle und die Angreifer benutzen dann häufig eben ihren eigenen IRC-Server.
Wer hat das gut unter Kontrolle? Die IRC-Netze?
Die IRC-Netze.
Was können die denn da überhaupt gegen tun?
Wenn man IRC-OP ist, dann kann man ja in Channels reingehen und kann dann eben schauen, was passiert dort, kann die Channels benden und solche Sachen.
Aber da sind doch extrem viele Leute am Wirken in diesen Netzwerken.
Also, können wir das überhaupt überblicken? Es gibt eben, sagen wir mittlerweile, einige automatisierte Methoden, um einfach mehr über Botnetze zu lernen. Dass man zum einen diese Bot-Binaries automatisch bekommt, dass man die automatisch analysieren kann und dann können wir beispielsweise automatisch so Channels identifizieren.
Okay, also so ein Channel auf Warnung hin. So nach dem Motto, irgendein Security-Researcher hat festgestellt, da ist ein Bot unterwegs und der dockt sich an dieses ERC-Net ran, dass man dann auch mit den Leuten explizit Kontakt aufnimmt und sagt, hier, pass mal auf, da gibt es das und das Kommunikationsschema von irgendwelchen Bots. Schaut doch mal, was ihr dagegen tun könnt, so die Richtung.
Genau, und deshalb häufig ist es mittlerweile so, dass sie einfach ihren eigenen Server irgendwo, dass sie irgendwo Mieten, irgendwo vielleicht konfrontiert mit einem Server haben, dort ein EC-Demon aufsetzen und einfach dort ihr eigenes EC-Netz aufsetzen.
Ja, wir wollten uns ja hier auch so ein bisschen auf die Bots konzentrieren, weil das irgendwie so, ja, weiß ich nicht, so ein bisschen der bedrohlichste Bereich zu sein scheint. Welche Verbreitung haben denn diese Botnetze heutzutage? Wie muss man sich denn das vorstellen? Gibt es da so ein paar und ab und zu findet man mal eins oder ist das irgendwie schon das jeder Rechner Teil eines Botnets ist?
Gute Frage. Also sowas zu messen ist echt schwierig. Also es gibt da wilde Schätzungen, was ich zu die höchste Schätzung nicht so kenne. Oder Leute sagen, dass so 25 Prozent der Maschinen im Internet konfrontiert sind. Das finde ich ein bisschen sehr hoch. 25 Prozent, ja. Das wären ja ein paar Hundert Millionen Rechner, die wir haben. Ich glaube, ich ist das ein bisschen hoch. Aber ich denke, irgendwo im Bereich von ein paar Millionen bewegen wir uns dort schon. Also wenn man eben so einige Botnetze sieht, die allein schon Hunderttausende Rechner haben. Und von diesen gibt es eben so einige größere. Und dann, wenn man das hochrechnet mit den ganzen kleinen. Also ich glaube schon irgendwo in einem Millionenbereich sind wir.
Aber wie sieht man denn das? Wie sieht man denn, dass ein Botnetz Millionen Mitglieder hat? Oder tausende oder wie viele auch immer?
Da gibt es eben verschiedene Techniken. Also was ich jetzt bei den zentralen Botnetzen, also die eben so einen zentralen Server haben, über die die Kommandos weiterverbreitet werden, dort kann man einfach sagen, wir zählen. Also man verbindet sich dann auch zu dem Channel und schaut dann, wie viele Bots kommen rein, gehen raus.
Also wenn es jetzt über ERC läuft?
Genau. Oder es gibt auch so Botnetze, die nutzen so peer-to-peer als Kommunikationsinfrastruktur, dass einfach die investierten Maschinen zum einen Client und auch Server sind. Und die waren dann so im peer-to-peer-Netz auf. Und dann kann man das peer-to-peer-Netz scrollen. Quasi kann man sich so vorstellen, dass jeder Bot hat so eine Peer-Liste, dass er einfach so ein paar weitere Bots kennt. Und wenn ich jetzt einen Bot frage nach seiner Peer-Liste, sagt er mir die. Dann nehme ich den ersten aus der Liste raus, frage den eben auch, welche Peers kennst du? Und mache das dann rekursiv einfach weiter. Und so kriege ich dann innerhalb von einer kurzen Zeit einen kompletten Überblick über das ganze Netz.
Du setzt aber voraus, dass man da quasi wie Untergleichen kommunizieren kann?
Genau, da muss man eben das Binary analysieren, das Protokoll verstehen, aber das kann man machen.
Das ist dann sozusagen Teil der Kunst?
Das ist Teil der Kunst, genau. Aber da, beispielsweise bei Storm oder so, also Stormo-ROM, das war so eins der großen Peer-to-Peer-Netze. 2008, bzw. auch 2007, da hatten wir eben so einen Crawler dafür. Und da haben wir dann typischerweise irgendwas zwischen 80.000 und 150.000 Maschinen online gesehen, zu einem gegebenen Zeitpunkt.
Das heißt, 80.000 bis 50.000 online, und dann kann man sich eine Dunkelziffer sozusagen mit hochrechnen, wie viele Rechner jetzt einfach gerade nicht laufen.
Genau, ja.
Sodass also durchaus wahrscheinlich ist, dass es Netze gibt, die mit höherer 6-stelliger Zahl oder vielleicht mehr, keine Ahnung, gab es schon mal mehr?
Also Conficker ist natürlich ein gutes Beispiel. Conficker kann man ja ziemlich gut tracken. Dort sind ja die aktuellen Zahlen immer noch im 6-Millionen-Bereich.
6-Millionen. Das ist viel. Und was sind das jetzt für Maschinen? Also was wird da jetzt tatsächlich? Sind das jetzt nur Windows-Rechner oder ist das alles Mögliche?
Also Windows ist eben so eins der Hauptziele. Klar, macht einfach Sinn, weil wir haben die Monokultur mit 90% oder so der Maschinen, wo Windows drauf läuft. Deshalb für einen Angreifer macht es einfach Sinn, Windows anzugreifen. Viele Bots laufen auch auf Windows, ganz klar. Allerdings gibt es eben auch, was ich angriffe, jetzt im Rahmen von Botnetzen gegen die Mac-Rechner. Dort sind die Tools allerdings noch nicht so wirklich weit. Die Bots sind dann häufig einfach Shell-Skripte. Die verändern einfach ein paar Systemeinstellungen. Beispielsweise bei den Mac-Bots ist es häufig so, die verändern dann deinen DNS-Server unter dem DNS-Server der Kontrolle des Angreifers. Was eigentlich schon ziemlich fies ist, weil die sehen dann alles, was du machst und können dich flexibel irgendwo anders redirecten. Es gibt natürlich auch Botnetze jetzt im Bereich Linux oder die BSDs. Das sind dann typischerweise irgendwelche Perl-Skripte nur, die dann einfach dafür sorgen, dass die infizierte Maschine auch zu einem ESC-Channel sich verbindet und dort eben auf Befehle wartet. Die werden dann häufig eher so für T-DOS und so Sachen benutzt.
Weil die meistens besser angebunden sind.
Genau so was, ja. Aber so Hauptziel oder Hauptmarkt in Anführungszeichen ist ganz klar Windows. Es gibt einfach die meisten Varianten und die meisten Opfer. Wie gesagt, die Monokultur. Dass das aus Angreifersicht einfach Sinn macht.
Und ist die Sicherheitslage denn bei den Betriebssystemen vergleichbar niedrig? Nehmen die sich alle nichts?
Also von technischer Sicht muss ich sagen, dass Windows mittlerweile echt gut geworden ist. Weil es war eines der besten Systeme, die wir haben. Windows 7 hat einfach echt gute Security-Features mittlerweile eingebaut. Die ganze Renovierung, das Ganze. Oder auch aus technischer Sicht ist Windows ganz nett geworden mittlerweile. Ich glaube, das Linux ist schon ein bisschen hinterher mittlerweile. Weil das Root einfach aller Rechte hat, ist einfach nicht mehr so cool mittlerweile.
Das beim Mac ja genauso.
Genau. Und wenn man sich anschaut, wie groß die Security-Updates sind, die Apple jeden Monat auf die Maschinen pusht, muss man sich auch irgendwie überlegen, wie gut sind diese Systeme eigentlich.
Ich muss ja immer noch meine eigenen Sendungen plagen. Ich bin schon lange nicht mehr so weit zurückgegangen. Chaosradio Express 22 ist schon eine Weile her, von 2006, vier Jahre. Aber das war ein Gespräch mit FX. Über die Weiterentwicklung eben genau bei Microsoft, was du sagst. Dieses Windows 95-Desaster, bzw. auch NT 2000, alles was noch danach kam, der Weg zu Vista. Im Prinzip, das was du jetzt sagst, Windows 7 ist sicher. Die Basis dafür wurde ja schon in der Entwicklung für Vista gelegt. Das war damals das Thema in der Sendung. Diese Konzepte interessieren, der mag da vielleicht auch noch mal reinhören. Jetzt nehmen wir das einfach mal so zur Kenntnis. Trotz alledem sind aber auch aktuelle Windows-Maschinen immer noch Opfer.
Also warum? Ich denke, da haben wir eben auch dieses ganze Wettrennen, was wir auch im kompletten Security-Bereich häufig sehen. Wenn man sich mal so anschaut, so 2004, 2005 oder auch schon 2003, gab es eben so viele Schwachstellen in ganzen Netzwerktdiensten, dass die ganzen RPC-Dienste von Windows einfach Fehler über, ohne Ende gefunden wurden. Diese DICOM-Schwachstellen, LSAS, diese ganzen Sachen, wo einfach die Angreifer aus der Ferne den RPC-Dienst exploitet haben und darüber dann das Einfallstor hatten.
Also RPC Remote Procedure Calls, explizit offen im Netz stehende Programmierschnittstellen, die man einfach so aufrufen kann, die sind natürlich besonders nackt. Weil das ist ja sozusagen direkt das direkte Andocken an einen Programmcode, wo dann Daten übergeben werden, die unter Umständen, wenn sie ein bisschen modifiziert sind, dann eben auf der Gegenseite schon Merkwürdigkeiten auslösen.
Genau, sobald man anfangen muss zu parsen, geht es ja irgendwie schief.
Das ist erstaunlich. Das hat ja auch ein bisschen was mit der Security-Kultur in den Köpfen der Programmierer zu tun. Ich denke, sowas wie Buffer-Overflows verhindern, also das Pufferspeicher, die man eben so vorhält, um die Daten erstmal aufzunehmen, um sie danach nach Empfang auszuwerten. Und dann haben die halt immer eine bestimmte Größe. Und wenn dann eben mehr Daten kommen als in den Puffer reinpassen, dann tendieren dann viele Programme dazu, einfach erst mal so lange zu schreiben, bis nichts mehr kommt. Und naja, bis es eigentlich schon lange nicht mehr geht. Aber sie schreiben dann halt irgendwo hin. Und wenn das eben gezielt ausgenutzt wird, kann dann eben auch dadurch wieder ein Türchen aufgemacht werden. Das ist natürlich etwas, was jetzt langsam einerseits auch in die Köpfe der Programmierer kommt, aber andererseits ist es ja auch eine Frage der Programmiersprachen und der Systeme, die man verwendet. Inwieweit sie das überhaupt zulassen.
Genau, ja, da haben wir auch denke ich viele gute Entwicklungen gesehen. Oder auch, dass die Compiler viel besser wurden. Dass es mittlerweile eben auch dort automatisierte Schutz-Mechanismen gibt. Oder eben auch diese Randomisierung oder diese Data Execution Prevention, also DEP, was einfach dafür sorgt, dass eine...
Können wir ruhig mal ein bisschen ausführen. Also was dann den... Bleiben wir noch mal kurz bei den konkreten Security-Bedrohungen. Weil ich würde auch gerne mal so ein bisschen verstehen, was macht eigentlich diese Systeme so unsicher. Man sagt immer so, naja, wenn du das und das installiert hast, dann ist irgendwie Polen offen und so. Aber letzten Endes fallen die ja alle aus denselben Gründen. Gut, Buffer-Overflow, denke ich, das habe ich jetzt schon mal ein bisschen skizziert. War das so was richtig? Muss man vielleicht gar nicht mehr so sehr viel mehr zu sagen. Nur dieses Verständnis, dass Daten, die man in einen anderen Computer hinein schreibt, quasi dazu führen, dass da ein Programm ausgeführt wird, was es so vorher nicht gab. Also man schreibt ja sozusagen direkt Code über das Netz rüber. Das setzt ja auch eine ganze Menge Wissen voraus über das System auf der anderen Seite. Da hilft es natürlich, dass man standardisierte oder zumindest weit verbreitete Plattformen hat, die man eben auf seinem eigenen Rechner genauso testen kann. Aber das geht ja auch nicht unbedingt jetzt für andere Systeme. Was sind denn so die anderen, also die typischen, wir müssen jetzt nicht ins letzte Detail gehen, aber was sind so diese typischen Angriffsvektoren und welche Maßnahmen auf der Verteidigerseite sozusagen, was du eben gerade angedeutet hast mit Randomisierung, haben jetzt dazu geführt, dass das eben nicht mehr so ein Problem ist.
Ja, vielleicht noch den Schritt eben von den schwachstellenden Netzwerkdiensten. Da wurde eben dort, da hat Microsoft viel gemacht oder im ganzen Security-Umfeld wurde viel gemacht. Dann hat sich so die Angriffe so ein bisschen verschoben auf die Browser, die ja relativ lange so im Zielfeld standen, weil das, weiß ich, das neue große Einfallstor war. Dort ist es häufig so, dass einfach schwachstellende Browser ausgenutzt wurden oder in den Plugins, häufig eben so getriggert, auch dann über JavaScript. Es gibt so eine Technik Heapspring. Das ist eben so die Standardidee, dass wenn ich jetzt irgendwelche Overflows triggern kann, kann ich teilweise nicht genau wissen, wohin ich springe. Weil das Sprungziel nicht komplett unter meiner Kontrolle ist. Und dann ist die Idee hinter diesen Sachen, dass ich quasi Datenstruktur in mir erzeuge auf dem Heap, die einfach ganz viele Knop-Operationen haben, und sich einfach gar nichts machen. Und dann am Ende habe ich ein kleines Stück Shell-Code, was dann die Befehle sind, die ich ausführen will.
Soll ich nochmal kurz sagen, was der Heap ist?
Ja, Heap quasi als, es gibt eben den Stack und den Heap, quasi so zwei Speicherbereiche, in denen das Programm quasi die Daten verwalten kann.
Also Stack ist sozusagen der Stapelspeicher, da wo man irgendwie immer drauf tut und wieder runternehmen kann.
Und der Heap eher so, was eben so ein bisschen automatisch gemanagt ist, wo meine Variablen in der Tabelle liegen und solche Sachen.
Wo sozusagen im Wesentlichen eigentlich so das Brain des Programms liegt. Und wenn man da halt beliebig reinschreibt, dann kann man nämlich alles Mögliche platzieren.
Genau, und dann mache ich einfach Heapsprayings in die Idee, dass ich einfach viele von diesen Nob-Slides bloß eben unten Sharecode drauflege. Also ein paar hundert Mal. Das sind so ein paar hundert Megabyte Speicher, die ich da alloziere. Und wenn ich dann irgendwo da reinspringe, ist die Chance einfach relativ groß, dass ich irgendwie in den Nob-Slide reinkomme, führe die aus. Also da werden keine Befehle ausgeführt und komme da unten in meinen Sharecode rein, der dann genau das macht, was ich will.
Also die Programme werden eigentlich so zermatert und einfach nur so komplett durchgesetzt mit irgendwie bitte bieg jetzt irgendwo ab, wo ich gerne hin möchte, sodass sie eigentlich schon dysfunktional sind und zwangsläufig eigentlich irgendwann auf die Nase fallen.
Genau, das ist eben dieses Programmieren von diesen Strange Machines. Wie kann ich ein Programm, was irgendwas macht, eben so umbiegen, dass es das macht, was ich machen will. Also jetzt aktuell, was ich so was wie JIT-Spraying, wo es eben darum geht, ich will eben irgendwie Flash exploiten, dass es so, ich füttere den Flash Interpreter, also Adobe Flash, füttere den mit irgendwelchen Input und sorge dann dafür, dass der Flash Interpreter quasi die Ausgabe von dem irgendwelche Shellcode ist. Und dann muss man eben schauen, was muss ich in den Interpreter reintun, dass hinten genau Shellcode rauskommt.
Also mit Shellcode meinst du sozusagen Code, der dazu führt, dass man die Shell kommt, also sozusagen auf die niedrigste Ebene des Rechners und dort eigentlich Zugriff auf alles hat.
Ja, beziehungsweise vor allem eben implementiert in Assembler. Also dass ich einfach dort Maschinenbefehle direkt ausführen kann. Genau. Und da ist eben der Trick, den Input für den Flash Interpreter so zu biegen, dass das, was rauskommt, genau Shellcode ist, den ich haben will. Weil da ist eben das Problem, das haben diese ganzen Just-In-Time-Compiler eigentlich, dass die Speicherpages müssen schreibbar sein, weil ich will ja zur Lauftheit erst den Code generieren, und müssen ausführbar sein. Ich habe also writable, unexecutable. Und dann kann der Angreifer irgendwie dafür sorgen, dass Befehle von seiner Wahl dort stehen, springt dahin hin und führt Sachen aus.
Das heißt, der JIT als Konzept verhindert sozusagen auch einen gewissen Schutz, weil eigentlich ja diese Bereiche nicht unbedingt schreibbar sind.
Genau, also JIT ist an sich ein tolles Konzept. Links auf Security-Sicht eben schwierig abzusichern eigentlich.
Ah, verstehe. Ja, logisch eigentlich. Was sind so die anderen Maßnahmen, die jetzt die Code-Qualität aber trotzdem verbessert haben?
Wie gesagt, ASLR, Azure Space Layout Randomisation. Es geht eben darum, dass ich jetzt Libraries und auch andere Stücke von Code einfach im Speicher nicht immer an Festadressen mappe, sondern das irgendwie randomisiere. Das hat eben aus Verteidiger-Sicht den Vorteil, dass der Eingreifer nicht mehr genau weiß, wo Code steht, damit er nicht irgendwo hinspringen kann. Für dort vorhandenen Code auszuführen, wenn ich das einfach randomisiere, also irgendwo zufällig in den Speicher reinmappe, habe ich quasi den Vorteil, dass ich Security by Obscurity eigentlich habe, dass der Eingreifer nicht weiß, wie ist mein Speicherlayout. Und deshalb habe ich da auch einen Art Schutz.
Genau, theoretisch könnte man immer noch hinspringen, aber man muss halt wissen, wo es ist und das weiß man eigentlich in dem Moment nicht.
Genau, ja.
Also ich weiß nicht, ist es Obscurity? Na gut, zumindest legt man seine Realitäten nicht so ohne weiteres auf den Tisch. Das ist ja schon mal ganz hilfreich. Das macht zum Beispiel Windows komplett, ne? Genau.
Mac macht es nicht komplett, aber ziemlich...
Teile davon auch.
Genau. Das ist eben auch so ein Standardkonzept.
Das heißt schon, das Betriebssystem, das ist ja im Prinzip, reden wir an der Stelle auch von einer Aufgabe des Betriebssystems, sozusagen so wie den Programm, die Systemressourcen zur Verfügung gestellt werden, dass an der Stelle eben schon diese Randomisierung stattfindet. Das heißt als Programmierer muss man das selber gar nicht machen. Sondern nur, weil das Betriebssystem das eben einfach selber schon mal so ein bisschen durchschüttelt und nicht alles linear und auf jedem Rechner identisch präsentiert, ist es schon sicherer.
Genau, ja. Andere verteidige Technik ist eben DEP, Data Execution Prevention. Das sorgt eben dafür, dass eine Speicherseite jetzt entweder schreibbar ist oder ausführbar. Also ich kann nicht beides haben, sondern writable or executable. Die modernen Prozessoren können das eben oder unterstützen das, dass es eben ein NX-Bit gibt, wo einfach gesagt wird, diese Seite ist nicht ausführbar. Und so hat man dann eben so eine etwas Trennung zwischen Code und Daten.
Das funktioniert aber dann wieder nicht mit diesen Jits.
Das funktioniert nicht mit Jits, genau.
Ist das richtig in Erinnerung, dass das bei Open BSD das erste Mal überhaupt zum Einsatz kam, diese Technologie?
Und dann Linux, das PAX-Team hat da ja auch viel gemacht damals. Mittlerweile, ja durch die Prozessor-Unterstützung ist das eigentlich super weiter, also hat fast jeder gemacht das eigentlich.
Also Windows macht das, der Mac macht das auch.
Der Mac macht das, Linux macht das, ja.
Klingt ja schon so, als würde das eigentlich das meiste verhindern können.
Ja, da kommen dann eben so aktuelle Technik, was jetzt so ein bisschen gehypt ist, dieses Return-Oriented Programming, wo die Idee ist, dass ich ja technisch erklärt, prinzipiell ist ja Return als Instruktion quasi das Ende bzw. eine Return Instruktion sorgt dafür, dass man danach wieder Kontrolle über, also wenn man irgendwo hin zurückspringt, was man...
Genau, also man will eine Subroutine aufrufen, Dinge, die man immer wieder tut, ruft die Subroutine und damit er weiß, wohin er zurückgeht, legt man eben die Rücksprungadresse in der Regel auf den Stack.
Genau.
So, und wenn dann die Routine fertig ist, holt sie sich quasi die Zurückkehrinformation eben von diesem Stack zurück und springt wieder dahin.
Genau, und jetzt ist eben der Trick quasi, gerade jetzt bei x86 funktioniert das eigentlich ganz gut. Ich schaue also durch meinen Speicher, suche nach Return Instruktionen und von dort aus disassembiere ich zurück und schaue einfach, was für Instruktionen stehen da vor.
Also bist du jetzt in der Angreifer-Position?
Genau, jetzt in der Angreifer. Ich suche also nach Returns, schaue mir, was ist da vor an Instruktionen. Da wird ein Register geladen, zwei Register werden addiert oder sonstige Sachen. Und wenn ich jetzt an die Stelle davor springe, ist es so, dass dann einfach ein, zwei Befehle ausgeführt werden. Danach kommt Return, also ich komme wieder zurück zum Stack. Kann also dort quasi die nächste Instruktion, wo ich hinspringen will, dort wieder ablegen. Dann springe ich, oder die Grundidee hinter ist, dass ich jetzt als Angreifer kein Code injecten muss, sondern ich nehme einfach den Code, der schon da ist und springe da ganz viel drum und nehme mir quasi immer diese Mikroinstruktionen, die quasi vor dem Return sind. Und wenn ich die clever kombiniere, beispielsweise ich lade zuerst mal ein Register, dann Return, lade ein anderes Register, ein Return und dann habe ich eine Instruktion, die zwei Register addiert, Return, wenn ich diese drei Micro-Gadgets quasi nach und dann ausführe, habe ich eine Addition gemacht. Und dann kann man quasi, wenn man das so clever kombiniert, kriegt man es eben hin, alles Mögliche zu machen. Man kann also einfach nur durch dieses Kombinieren von den Returns quasi beliebig Code ausführen.
Das heißt, man schreibt gar nicht seinen eigenen Code, sondern man schaut sich den Code an, der da ist und sucht sich da quasi irgendein Sprungmuster raus, was dann so das Richtige tut und das ist das dann, was man durch den eigentlichen Security-Angriff auf der Gegenmaschine platziert, so nach dem Motto, spring noch mal dahin, spring noch mal dahin, spring noch mal dahin. Und da liegt dann schon irgendwelcher Code, der aber nicht von mir ist, sondern ganz normale Sachen ist. Aber nur dadurch, dass man ihn anders anspringt, tut er quasi etwas für einen, was so eigentlich gar nicht intendiert war.
Genau, und deshalb gibt mir sowas wie WX einfach nicht, weil ich muss ja keinen Code reinbringen, sondern einfach den Code, der schon da ist.
Aber trotzdem muss doch da irgendwie Code platziert werden, der dann überhaupt erst mal diese Sprünge ausführt?
Ne, da muss ich eigentlich nur auf den Stack einfach nur die Adressen hinlegen, wo ich das nächste hin springen will. Weil wenn ich das Return ausführe, sorgt der quasi dafür, dass vom Stack die nächste Adresse benutzt wird und da wird dann hingesprungen. Also mein Stack-Pointer wird auf einmal so der Instruction-Pointer. Und ich muss auf meinen Stack einfach nur die Adressen hinlegen, wie ich so das Sprung musste.
Aber auf dem kann man ja mal mehr oder weniger problemlos schreiben auf dem Stack, weil dafür ist er da.
Genau, und wirklich ist das richtig. Also ich leg da einfach meine Adressen hin, wo ich hinspringen will und für das Ganze zu triggern am Anfang, dafür brauch ich eben eine Schwachstelle, dass ich eben einmal vier Byte überschreiben kann, für so meinen ersten Jump zu machen quasi und danach der Rest funktioniert so.
Gute Güte, da sieht es aber aus, als ob einige 14-Jährige sich damit ihre Nachmittage verbraten haben mit solchen Analysen.
Eigentlich nur 14-Jährige, das machen wir auch an der Uni.
Okay, auch 20-Jährige. Ich habe jetzt von vorhin noch Randomisierung in Erinnerung. Hast du das schon erwähnt oder?
ASLR, diese Atmos-Base-Layout-Randomisation, dann DEP als Schutzechnik, dann gibt es ja einige Techniken, um einfach so den Stack quasi zu schützen, dass man dort Zusatzinfos drauflegt, um die Intrigität zu checken, oder dass man auch die Intrigität der ganzen Listen, die es Windows so verwaltet, dass man die checkt und sonstige Sachen, dass die Compiler mittlerweile automatisch einfach Schutzmechanismen in den Code mit einbauen und dann einfach zur Laufzeit auch checken, ob einfach noch alles stimmt oder ob der Hieb jetzt auf einmal, was wie jetzt irgendwie korrupt ist oder sowas, dass sie sowas auch checken können.
Wenn man jetzt nochmal zurückgeht zu dem, was jetzt sozusagen wirklich Angriffsziele sind. Also war es halt lange Zeit sozusagen das Betriebssystem selbst, die Bibliotheken, die da mitkommen. Jetzt hat sich da einiges getan, bei allen, mehr oder weniger, besonders viel bei Windows, aber da war, glaube ich, auch eine ganze Menge zu tun. Und jetzt, sagtest du, sind es ja unter anderem die Browser oder sind es vor allem die Browser? Ich weiß nicht.
Also vor allem Browser, obwohl die mittlerweile auch echt gut geworden sind. Wenn man sich jetzt aktuelle Browser anschaut, sehe ich IE8, Chrome oder auch Safari, die jetzt auch viele Schutzkonzepte umsetzen. Weil so ein weiteres Schutzkonzept ist ja dieses Sandboxing, dass ich also quasi, wenn ich Code ausführe, einfach dafür sorge, dass der nur so seinen eigenen kleinen Sandkasten hat, indem wir machen, was er will. Und wenn der Ankäfer jetzt eine Schwachstelle in diesem Code findet, ist er immer nur im Sandkasten drin. Das ist eben schon eigentlich auch ein gutes Konzept. Wird auch in Browsern jetzt viel implementiert mittlerweile. Es wäre jetzt irgendeine Seite, irgendwie ein Bug, triggered bei meinem Browser. Stürzt einfach nur der eine Tab ab und dann ist es okay, die anderen Tabs funktionieren einfach weiter.
Bei Chrome?
Bei Chrome zum Beispiel, genau.
Bei Safari wäre es schon der ganze Browser.
Genau, aber das wird hier hoffentlich irgendwann machen, hier ist es auch richtig, dass man dort auch den Prozess und das Ganze so trennt voneinander und so. Das kommt eben auch. So Sandboxing als Konzept.
Also in WebKit kommt es ja konkret direkt rein. Also derzeit macht es nur Chrome, obwohl sie WebKit sowieso auch noch verwenden. An der WebKit kommt es dann auch selber noch rein, das ist zumindest angekündigt. Da bleibt natürlich immer noch ein bisschen dieses Internet Explorer 6-Problem, dieser super verbreitete Browser, den keiner so richtig aktualisieren will. Das ist natürlich auch ein Rieseneinfallstor.
Da hat man ja Anfang dieses Jahres wieder gesehen, diese Operation Aurora, wo einfach etwas mehr als 30 Firmen wirklich gezielt angegriffen wurden. Dort einfach Schwachsteller auch im EE6, wie dann Zero Day in EE, wo dann Firmen wie Google, Adobe oder auch so regierungsnahe Firmen in den USA einfach angegriffen wurden. Einigermaßen oder ziemlich professionell eigentlich durchgeführt. Und das war dann wahrscheinlich auch wirklich die Industrie-Spionage.
Da fragt man sich, warum das eigentlich so schwierig ist, diesen Firmen diese alte Software zu entziehen, wenn sie doch so große Fehler sind.
Das ist eine gute Frage. Weil EE6 ist von wann? 2005? 2004? Also auf jeden Fall alt.
Gute Frage. Ich gucke mal nach. Auf jeden Fall alt und vor allem auch sehr bekannt dafür, viele Fehler zu haben. Aber es ist ja auch nicht nur der Internet Explorer 6, es ist ja auch noch das gute alte Windows 95. Das ist ja irgendwie auch noch nicht aus der Welt.
Obwohl die Maschine häufig nicht am Netz ist, so glücklich.
Also Version 6 erschien am 27. August 2001. Also das ist schon richtig alte Scheiße. Und dann erst fünf Jahre später gab es irgendwie eine neue Version. Also das Ding ist schon bald zehn Jahre alt. Und wenn man jetzt von dir hört, seit zehn Jahren geht es irgendwie richtig rund, ist natürlich klar, dass das sozusagen der Urknall ist. Wobei, keine Ahnung, ich glaube die noch ältere Versionen sind eigentlich kaum noch wirklich aktiv. Aber die Plugins hast du ja auch schon angesprochen, Flash zum Beispiel.
Ja, hat ja auch. Genau so denke ich mal so nach den Angriffen auf die Browser, wurden die Browser eben immer besser. Und deshalb so das neue Ziel sind eben häufig diese Plugins, die man irgendwie als Ziel hat als Angreifer. Dort Flash natürlich oder eben auch Adobe, das PDF-Produkt.
Also Acrobat Reader.
Entschuldigung, klar, der Acrobat Reader, der einfach hier auch eine große Liste an Security Bugs hat in letzter Zeit.
Was ist denn der Grund dafür, dass die so angreifbar sind? Ich meine, Adobe lebt doch auch in dieser Welt. Die müssten das doch irgendwie auch schon mal gehört haben.
Hören und verstehen ist ja auch noch ein Unterschied. Aber ich meine, mit denen wird doch auch geredet. Ja, aber das Security-Team von Adobe ist nicht unbedingt groß und die sind im Moment noch sehr stark im Lernprozess, würde ich sagen, dass sie erst jetzt diese ganzen, was ich so was wie SDL, also den Security Development Lifecycle, so was umsetzen oder eben wirklich auch ihre Programmierer quasi dazu bringen, dass sie eben Security-Aware sind. Das ist glaube ich bei Adobe im Moment noch so die Lernphase, dass sie eben auch Schutzkonzepte wie, was ich so, Sandboxing oder sowas wirklich in den Reader einbauen. Wird noch ein bisschen dauern, aber ich glaube Adobe bekommt im Moment einfach so viele Schläge, die werden jetzt langsam mal was tun müssen. Und dort haben wir auch wieder diese Monokultur, einfach Flash und der Reader auf über 90 Prozent der Maschinen installiert.
Und es gibt nur eine Implementierung davon.
Genau und als Angreifer macht es einfach Sinn, dort nach Bugs zu suchen, weil dann hat man einfach die große Masse an Leuten wieder. Also gerade jetzt der Reader hatte letztes Jahr mindestens zehn Lücken, die jeweils Code Execution waren. Und da müssen die jetzt was tun.
Und das ist viel im Verhältnis zu den anderen oder sind die anderen auch alle so schlimm? Also ich meine, wer führt denn jetzt wirklich so die Hall of Shame derzeit an?
Aus meiner Sicht Adobe. Weil die haben mit Flash und mit dem PDF-Reader einfach so zwei Dauerziele drin.
Die ja auch noch so ganz exponiert installiert sind. Greift dieses Sandboxing in der Browser dann irgendwie nicht?
Bei Flash hat man wieder das Problem, dass eben die Memorypages auch wieder executable sein sollen. Deshalb da ist das nicht Sandboxing, achso, weil da wieder JIT drin ist und so weiter. Bei PDF hilft es natürlich, das muss ich ja nur anzeigen und wenn ich das Sandboxe, dann funktioniert es ganz gut. Und ich denke, dass wir auch bald Sandboxing haben für diese ganzen Flash-Sachen. Da gibt es auch schon Ideen, wie man das machen kann. Das ist ein bisschen technisch komplizierter, aber ich denke, das wird in Zukunft hoffentlich besser werden. Genau, also technisch gibt es viele Schwachstellen, aber es gibt natürlich auch noch diesen Layer-8, der Mensch, der einfach vor dem PC sitzt. Und das ist eben auch noch definitiv das Problem, dass einfach aus Angreifersicht das super einfach ist. Ich schicke einfach eine E-Mail, wo einfach drin steht, hallo, du hast eine Kurskarte bekommen, klick mal auf diesen Link. Oder öffne das Attachment, um die Kurskarte zu sehen. Und die Leute machen es einfach. Die öffnen das Attachment, die gehen auf die Webseite. Die Webseite versucht dann vielleicht einfach, einen Bug in meinem Browser auszunutzen. Wenn das nicht erfolgreich ist, wird dem Benutzer einfach das Binary zum Download angeboten. Postcard.exe und die klicken einfach drauf.
Die tun's.
Haben wir einfach, beispielsweise noch mal zurückzukommen zu diesem Stormwarm, also dieses P2P-Netz, was wir crawlen konnten, wo wir dann eben wirklich so alle Stunde einfach geschaut haben, wie viele Maschinen sind jetzt gerade online. Hat man dann wirklich so schön die Kurve gesehen, so der 23. Dezember. Dort haben die Angreifer dann einfach angefangen, hier diese Art von Kurskarten zu schicken.
Aus diesem Netz heraus.
Genau, aus diesem Netz heraus. Und dann an Silvester eben nochmal so eine Welle. Und dann sind einfach 50.000 neue Maschinen einfach hinzugekommen innerhalb von ein paar Tagen. Und das sind ja nur die Maschinen, die gerade online sind. Die Dummke Ziffer ist ja dann wieder ein paar Mal höher.
Gibt es denn da überhaupt irgendeinen Schutz vor? Also ich meine, dieses lad dir nicht alles runter, dann klickt nicht überall drauf-Ding.
Ja, also technisch können wir ja viel machen, was ich über die Randomisierung, diese nicht-Ausführbarkeit von Daten und sowas. Aber dann den Nutzer vor sich selbst schützen, da wird es dann schwierig.
Ja, vor allem, wenn ich mir selber ein Executable runterlade und das dann starte, das ist ja in den meisten Fällen ja auch so gewollt. Ich lade mir neue Software runter. Im Prinzip müsste man eigentlich auch diesen Kanal zumachen. Und bevor wirklich Software dann vollständig zur Ausführung kommt, oder ist das so, was man so lernen muss?
Da muss man glaube ich auch noch was tun, weil es ist eigentlich auch blöd, wenn ich ein Programm ausführe und das darf dann auf einmal mein ganzes Team verändern. Das sollte eigentlich auch nicht so sein. Gibt es ja jetzt auch gute Techniken oder einige Techniken mittlerweile, was ich, wenn das Programm meinetwegen auf C, Windows, System32 schreiben will, kriege ich quasi so eine virtuelle Instanz davon. Aus Programmsicht sieht es so aus, als ob das erfolgreich gewesen ist, aber das wird dann transparent einfach umgeleitet in einen anderen Ordner.
Eine virtuelle Instanz dieser Datei.
Genau, des Systems. Aus Programmsicht sieht es aus, als ob das jetzt wirklich erfolgreich war und dort in den Ordner geschrieben hat, in einen der Systemordner von Windows. Aber eigentlich hat Windows das Ganze umgebogen in den Anwendungsordner von den Programmen. Also andere Programme sind einfach nicht davon betroffen. So was macht Sinn.
Also eigentlich auch wieder die Idee des Handboxings, dass man also wirklich den Code erstmal in so einen Sandkasten setzt und dann kann er da irgendwie bauen und rumspielen, wie er möchte, aber er tut irgendwie keinem was zu leide.
Genau, muss man eben schauen, weil das kann man nicht immer so machen. Weil beispielsweise ich will ja, dass mein Musikprogramm meine ganze Platte lesen kann und alles indizieren kann und sowas, aber ich muss eben irgendwie trotzdem schauen, dass ich im Programm nicht wichtige Sachen verändern kann. Ich denke, da müssen wir auch noch schauen, dass wir da eben diese Schutzkonzepte noch besser umsetzen.
Ja, schreiten natürlich dann so ein bisschen nach so einem komplett geschlossenen Installationssystem für Software.
Ja, das ist natürlich schwierig. Also über Code-Signing und so kann man natürlich auch viel machen, dass ich eben alles signiere und dann, was ich nur signierte, Dateien ausführe, sowas gibt es ja auch. Nur, dann habe ich eben das Problem, dass ich jetzt freie Software, wenn ich die benutzen will, hat der Entwickler vielleicht dort einfach nicht einen offiziellen Key oder ich will mir auch etwas selber kompilieren und sonstige Sachen. Da muss man eben schauen, wo schränkt man einen Nutzer wirklich ein und wo macht es aus Sicherheit keinen Sinn. Also dieser Trade-off zwischen Security und Usability, hat man ja häufig.
Ja, ist klar. Dann könnte man natürlich auch dual rangehen und sagen, wenn das jetzt hier irgendwie halbwegs sicher signiert ist und von einer vertrauenswürdigen Instanz, sei es mein Betriebssystemhersteller oder wen auch immer, ich als vertrauenswürdige Instanz da ansehe, meine Firma, dass das dann auch sofort läuft und wenn das nicht der Fall ist, dass ich dann zumindest so einen bedrohlichen Dialog bekomme oder das Starten in so einer Sandbox, dass selbst wenn das Ding jetzt irgendwie versucht, schlimme Sachen zu machen, dass es erstmal keine Wirkung hat, solange ich das eben explizit freischalte.
Genau, ja.
Schon vorstellbar, oder?
Die Security oder die AV-Industrie macht im Moment ja auch sonstige Sachen. Also sowas in dem Bereich.
Welche Industrie?
AV, Anti-Viren-Industrie. Diese cloudbasierten Ansätze, wo quasi die Idee ist, jedes Mal wenn ich ein Programm ausführe, wird davon irgendwie so ein Hechwert berechnet. Der Hechwert wird in die Cloud geschickt. Dort wird eben gecheckt, wie viele Leute haben diesen gleichen Hech, oder wer führt das auch aus. Weil kann man sich das vorstellen, wenn ich jetzt einfach Notepad.exe aufrufe, darüber Hechwert, schickt in die Cloud, und schon 100.000 andere Leute haben diese gleiche Datei ausgeführt, also ist die wahrscheinlich gutartig. Und wenn ich jetzt einfach auf einmal irgendwelche Schadsoftware habe, davor der Hechwert hat eben noch niemand gesehen, dann ist das eben irgendwie schon ein bisschen komisch auf jeden Fall. Sollte man vielleicht dem Nutzer Bescheid sagen.
Aber wenn jetzt ein neues Release von der Software rauskommt?
Ja, das sind diese Probleme, mit denen wir noch so ein bisschen kämpfen müssen.
Das heißt, man muss dann irgendwann erstmal so seinen Hechwert an diese Security-Buden abgeben und sagen, hier demnächst kommt neues Photoshop, merkt euch doch schon mal den Key.
Ja, das ist schwierig, da haben die auch noch nicht so ganz unter Kontrolle.
Ja, das kann ich mir gut vorstellen. Zumal dadurch auch wieder ein neuer Angriffsvektor erstellt wird, nämlich diese Betreiber dieser Sicherheitswolken.
Das wollen die Security, also das will die AV gar nicht hören.
Ja, ja, ich meine diese AV, wie du so schön sagst, die Anti-Viren-Industrie, die ist ja nun auch schon seit längerem dabei. Wie wohlgelitten ist die denn so in der Security-Szene? Ich meine, ich will jetzt nicht gleich mit Verschwörungstheorien aufkommen, mit man macht sich seinen eigenen Markt, das ist nicht das, was ich sagen will. Diese Diskussion gibt es ja auch immer wieder, aber wie effizient sind die denn nun tatsächlich beim Beheben von Sicherheitsproblemen?
Gute Frage. Das höre ich immer gerne. Ja, also, Frage, wie man das jetzt am besten diplomatisch irgendwie austritt. Also wir haben so einige Methoden, um jetzt automatisiert neue Schadsoftware zu sammeln. So eine Honeypot, da können wir später mal drauf eingehen. Da bekommen wir einfach mit, welche Art oder was für Schadsoftware im Moment so aktuell im Netz unterwegs ist. Und ist dann so, wenn wir jetzt ein neues Exemplar quasi gefunden haben, wenn wir das dann checken gegen viele von diesen AV-Produkten, dort gibt es eben virustotal.com als Service. Dort kann man einfach eine Datei hochladen. Und die checken das dann gegen um die 40 verschiedene Hersteller. Die prüfen das also mit der Engine von den Herstellern und geben dann einem so das Resultat. Dort sehen wir dann häufig, dass die Erkennungsraten irgendwo im Bereich zwischen 30 und 70 Prozent sind. Also viele AV-Produkte erkennen es einfach noch gar nicht. Im Extremfall ist es einfach so, dass vielleicht nur ein, zwei Produkte das erkennen. Das ist eben die Detection-Raten, die man so aus den typischen Tests kennt, dort so 99,999 Prozent erkannt wird, ist nicht so ganz das, was wir so in der Realität sehen. In einer der letzten CTs gab es eben auch einen Test, da haben die es auch mal so ein bisschen besser getestet, mit so auch das ganze Neupacken, also man so eine gegebene Datei nochmal obfuscate, also obfuscated. Dort sind dann die Detection-Raten eben auch deutlich gesunken, das ist auf so 60 Prozent Erkennungsrate ist schon echt gut eigentlich. Also diese AV-Industrie hat im Moment auch glaube ich einen hohen Lernprozess, weil traditionell haben die es hier jeweils gemacht mit so Signaturen, also ich suche nach irgendwelchen Hash-Werten oder nach irgendwelchen Prüf-Summen innerhalb der inneren Datei. Und wenn das eben gegen meine Datenbank von Chart Software irgendwie, ich doch einen Match habe, das sage ich einem, das ist böse. Nur die haben das Problem, dass die Angreifer mittlerweile einfach automatisiert neue Varianten erzeugen, so Polymorph das Ganze machen oder einfach alle fünf Minuten einfach ein neues binary erzeugen und dass die jetzt pro so die typischen Zahlen aus der AV-Industrie ist, dass die pro Tag irgendwas so im Bereich von 50.000 neue Samples bekommen. Und da kann man sich vorstellen, wenn die von diesen 50.000 Samples Hash-Werte erzeugen, werden die Datenmanken einfach relativ schnell groß. Deshalb dieser ganze sich naturbasierte Ansatz funktioniert sowieso nicht so ganz. Gibt es jetzt eben so auch ein Umdenken seit ein paar Jahren, dass man eher in diesen verhaltensbasierten Ansatz reingeht, um zu schauen, verhält sich das Programm zur Laufzeit irgendwie komisch. Geht so ein bisschen gegen das Business-Modell, was die haben, weil es ja etwa so ist, dass ich kaufe mir die Engine, bekomme regelmäßig meine Updates, kostet irgendwie 50, 60 Euro pro Jahr. Und wenn ich jetzt auf einmal eine gute Detection-Engine habe, ist es ja so, dass ich dort nicht unbedingt mehr meine Sachen verkaufen kann. Weil wenn ich eine richtig gute Engine habe, die böses Verhalten quasi perfekt erkennt, mache ich meinen ganzen Markt kaputt oder so.
Also erkennen im Sinne von, dass man generell einen Algorithmus hat, mit dem man Böses erkennt oder mit dem man nur Bekanntes Böses nachvollziehen kann. Du verhältst dich wie der Virus, den wir da schon kennen.
Das Schöne wäre natürlich, wenn man es wirklich so generischer hat, also so generischer Heuristiken beispielsweise, der versucht, sich ins Systemverzeichnis zu schreiben oder der macht den Autorun-Key. Ist natürlich nicht unbedingt böse, weil ein Installer macht sowas Ähnliches. Deshalb ist das insgesamt auch ein schwieriges Problem. Wie erkennt man sowas überhaupt? Aber da sind die jetzt auch relativ stark im Entwickeln. Mal schauen, was da Gutes rauskommt.
Ok, also ein klassisches Beispiel für diesen Wettbewerb und diesen Lauf, den sich beide Seiten gegenseitig bieten. Das heißt, um es mal ein bisschen zusammenzufassen, man kann sagen, die Betriebssysteme als solche machen große Fortschritte. Auch das, was lange Zeit im Verruf stand, einfach ein einziges Scheudentor zu sein, nämlich diese Windows-Familie, hat sich zumindest in den letzten Versionen deutlich gebessert. Schon mit Vista, mit Windows 7 vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen. Ich weiß nicht, wie groß der Security-Fortschritt war. Kannst du das einschätzen?
Ja, schon ein paar Konzepte, aber es waren eher so Details, dass die...
Also nochmal verfeinert, was diese Kraftanstrengung von Vista gebracht hat. Ich meine, das war ja auch eine irre Zeit. Man hatte das Gefühl, dass sämtliche Security-Hacker auf diesem Planeten irgendwie bei Microsoft arbeiten. Das war wirklich faszinierend. Da muss man sozusagen Microsoft auch auf die Schulter klopfen für, dass sie das dann zu dem Zeitpunkt aber auch wirklich massiv betrieben haben. Also sie haben wirklich enorm verstanden, dass sie da ein ganz, ganz, ganz großes Problem haben und sie haben es dann auch wirklich mit der Keule erschlagen.
Was die an Fussing-Infrastruktur dort haben mittlerweile, ist schon ziemlich imposant, muss man sagen.
Was weiß du darüber?
Die fassen alles Mögliche.
Fussing ist diese Technik, dass man, vielleicht kannst du auch noch mal kurz etwas erläutern.
Also prinzipiell ist die Idee, ich fütter ein Programm einfach mit vielen verschiedenen Arten von Inputs und schaue einfach, wie reagiert das Programm. Das kann man entweder ganz, ganz dumm machen, indem man einfach nur, meinetwegen ich habe eine Datei und flip in der Datei einfach mal ein Bit und gebe das dem Programm zum Pasen, also damit das öffnet beispielsweise. Und es kann eben sein, dass wenn ich das eine Bit flippe, dass dadurch eben aus einer ganz großen Zahl auf einmal eine ganz kleine Zahl wird oder andersrum. Und dass das Programm dann, oder die Programmlogik, die irgendwie auseinanderbringt. Das kann man noch so ein bisschen besser machen, indem man quasi so systematisch die Programm-Fade absucht. Und das wird dann relativ schnell relativ komplex. Aber dass man einfach so systematisch studiert, wie reagiert ein Programm auf unbekannten Input oder Input, der jetzt genau die Spezifikation verletzt beispielsweise. Sodass man einfach testet, wie gut ist eigentlich die Codequalität. Das ist quasi so die Grundidee. Also ich werfe Input gegen das Programm und gucke, wann fällt es um. Und die haben eben viele Techniken in dem Bereich entwickelt. Sowohl einfach dieses ganze dumme Fuzzing superweit entwickelt, als auch das ganze Intelligent-Machen, dass man wirklich schaut, ok, ich muss jetzt genau diesen Input rein geben, um nach 100 Verzweigungen einmal links abzubiegen quasi. Da haben die auch relativ viel gemacht. Und die haben da auch jede Menge Maschinen stehen, die einfach nur tagelang oder wochenlang einfach nur neuen Input generieren für die Programme.
Also die Software wird einfach mit irgendwelchem random Zeug beballert. Und wenn es irgendwelche Anormalitäten gibt, dann werden die halt automatisch erkannt.
Genau, ja. Also nicht nur random, teilweise auch wirklich so konstruiert, dass man wirklich dediziert bestimmte Programmpfade findet. Und dort haben die intern jede Menge Tools, die quasi nur das machen.
Ja, so teste ich immer neue Software, die mir irgendwie auf den Rechner kommt. Nicht so sehr auf Security-Low-Level-Ebene, sondern sowas, was das User interface betrifft. Da kann man auch über erstaunliche Ergebnisse erzählen. Neulich habe ich dann mal den Programmierer nebenbei dann sozusagen. Also er schaute mir sozusagen über die Schulter. Und dann so blickte er schon ganz entsetzt, als wir auf einmal Dateien haben mit Lehrzeichen und sowas gemacht habe. Das erwartet dann halt immer irgendwie der Programmierer nicht. Das ist ja auch ein richtig mentales Problem des Programmierers, der ja eigentlich immer weiß, wie es richtig sein müsste. Genau. Und der auch selber natürlich seine Programme immer so benutzt, wie er weiß, dass sie funktionieren. Niemand kommt auf die Idee, die eigene Software anders zu benutzen, als es eben von dem Programmierer selbst gedacht war. An der Stelle muss man glaube ich auch immer so ein bisschen, ja weiß ich gar nicht, was man da am besten machen kann. Also entweder die ganze Zeit mit Testern zusammenarbeiten, die einem das eben unterm Arsch wegtesten, so wie das ja eben dann in großen Firmen läuft, oder eben auch einfach selber mal so ein bisschen den Mut haben, gegen die Kiste zu treten.
Ich glaube, das ist ja, wo die Angreifer echt gut sind, einfach.
Genau, weil ich war ja gerade ein bisschen beim Zusammenfassen. Also bei Windows ist es nun sehr viel besser geworden. Ob es ausreicht, das wird man sehen. Es gibt das Problem, dass eben populäre Plugins, die sich jetzt in populären Programmen, also vor allem natürlich Browsern, niederschlagen, wie zum Beispiel Flash, wie zum Beispiel Acrobat. Es gibt sicherlich auch noch ein paar andere, aber es gibt wenige, die jetzt so populär sind. Oder gibt es noch irgendwas, was noch ein bisschen aus dem Rahmen fällt?
Was natürlich noch ein großes Einflachtstor war, waren auch diese ganzen Office-Produkte. PowerPoint, Excel, Word. Da gab es natürlich auch eine Zeit lang, wo die ähnlich wie der Browser so das große Ziel waren.
Aber dann mehr so über Dateien, die ihnen gegeben werden. Hier, mach mal das PPT auf, mach mal und so weiter.
Genau, die kann man teilweise auch eben über Plugins triggern, diese Sachen, aber das ist häufig einfach, dass man wirklich dem Opfer das zuschickt und eröffnet es einfach. Und dann geht es kaputt.
Also populäre Software. Wir haben ja wieder dieses Monokulturproblem in jeder Hinsicht. Aber offensichtlich gibt es diese Löcher. Die sind einfach da. Vielleicht kann man jetzt mal ein bisschen mehr darauf eingehen, wie das mit diesen Botnets jetzt eigentlich wirklich funktioniert, beziehungsweise was war so das erste Botnet, was man als solches auch bezeichnet hat. Wann kam das auf? Wann war klar, dass das jetzt sozusagen ein erkennbares Problem darstellt?
Also die ersten Sachen, die groß wurden, oder eher so bekannter wurden, waren so diese ganzen DDoS-Angriffe, die wir so 2002 gesehen haben.
Also Distributed Denial of Service verteilt von verschiedenen Maschinen mit dem Ziel, einfach die Maschinen überhaupt erst mal davon abzubringen, das zu tun, was sie normalerweise tun.
Genau, also man schickt jede Menge Anfragen und dann entweder kann die Maschine die Anfragen nicht mehr handeln oder die ganze Leitung ist dicht einfach mit Anfragen und der Zielrechner ist einfach effektiv nicht mehr reichbar.
Das ist so Netz-Hooliganismus, oder? Das war am Anfang...
Genau.
Wer hat sich damit auseinandergesetzt? Das war Because We Can.
Because We Can, ja, vor allem eben auch, dass man so was wie Ebay oder Amazon damals angegriffen hat. Und dann wirklich auch diese großen Seiten, also damals klar nicht ganz so groß wie heutzutage, aber die wirklich stundenlang einfach nicht mehr reichbar waren.
Was denkst du, was war die Motivation am Anfang?
Ich glaube, das war For Fun.
Das war doch wieder bei den 14-Jährigen.
Ja, ich glaube, er war 16 oder so.
16?
So ein Kanadier.
Ah, okay, ich will jetzt die 14-Jährigen auch nicht zu sehr in den Verruf bringen, aber das ist so etwa der Zeitpunkt, wo ich mir das sehr gut vorstellen kann.
Genau, und das war eben auch Botnetze so als Tool quasi, weil da braucht der Angreifer ja viele Maschinen unter seiner Kontrolle, dass er einfach denen sagt, schickt mal jede Menge Anfragen an Amazon.
Also Denial of Service, in dem Namen steckt ja sozusagen erst mal nur dieses, wir greifen euch so an, damit ihr eure normale Dienstleistung nicht mehr durchführen kann, aber im Prinzip reden wir jetzt schon über den nächsten Schritt, nämlich dieses, nicht nur, dass es distributiert ist, sondern dadurch, dass das alles in die Knie geht, macht ihr überhaupt erst mal Sicherheitslücken auf, die so im Normalbetrieb nicht vorhanden sind? Oder macht man den Denial-of-Service von irgendwelchen Verteidiger-Systemen? So ist das ja auch nicht, oder?
Denial-of-Service alleine sich dagegen zu schützen, ist auch schon schwierig, weil wenn jetzt Slashdot auf meinen Blog linkt, dann habe ich auf einmal auch tausend Leute, die hinkommen und da so semantisch unterscheiden, sind das jetzt normale Besucher oder sind das jetzt Bots, ist eben auch schwierig. Und ja, ich glaube, das ist eben, DDoS ist an sich ein Problem. Man kann natürlich sich ein bisschen schützen, indem man eine große Leitung hinbringt oder irgendwo relativ früh anfängt zu filtern.
Ja, aber du hast ja jetzt gesagt, vielleicht habe ich es nicht richtig verstanden, aber ich dachte, du meinst, das so mit DDoS fing es irgendwie an, aber letzten Endes muss ja das Botnetz, muss ich ja irgendwo erst mal, muss ich ja überhaupt erst mal auf diese Rechner bringen. Also hat sich durch dieses DDoS dann sozusagen Sicherheitslücken aufgefahren, die dann ausgenutzt wurden? Oder war das sozusagen erst mal nur dieses Phänomen, dass man überhaupt erst mal gegen das Netz vorging?
Nix war eher so, der Angreifer hatte damals eben viele Maschinen so kompromittiert über andere Schwachstellen, dann da eben den Bot drauf installiert und dann diese infizierten Linus-Maschinen waren es glaube ich alles.
Um damit DDoS zu machen?
Um damit DDoS zu machen, genau.
Also DDoS ist sozusagen schon ein Zeichen dessen, dass es Botnetze gab.
Also Stachentrat war damals so eines der ersten Tools, die so entdeckt wurden auf konfrontierten Rechnern.
Stacheldraht hieß das.
Und das zweite Tool, fällt mir jetzt der Name nicht ganz ein. Dave Dietrich hat damals so die ersten Analysen gemacht. Stacheldraht und das zweite. Na fällt mir gerade nicht ein wie das hieß.
Also Stacheldraht war sozusagen der Name des Netztes, was sich dann daraus ergab oder der Software, die sich dann in diese Rechner hineingebracht hat. Hat sie die selber so genannt oder wurde die so genannt?
Ich glaube, die hieß selber so. Dave Dietrich ist eigentlich ein Amerikaner. Deshalb denke ich, hat er sich den Namen nicht ausgedacht, sondern hat ihn wahrscheinlich irgendwo gesehen und dann so genutzt. Genau, das waren so quasi die Grundzüge von den Botnetzen, die wir damals so gesehen hatten. Also viele Maschinen wurden irgendwie kompromittiert. Dort wurden eben der Stacheldraht-Client drauf installiert. Die Clients wussten dann irgendwo, wo sie Befehle herbekommen. Und der Angreifer schickt dann die Befehle zu diesen kompromottierten Maschinen. Und die werden dann für dieses DDoS benutzt.
Den gibt es aber hier immer noch so schön im Netz zum Runterladen mit irgendwie kompletter Analyse und Southcode.
Genau, ja. Wahrscheinlich auf der Seite von Dave kann das sein.
Ich habe das jetzt hier einfach in der englischen Wikipedia gefunden. In Deutschland ist halt nur von Stacheldraht die Rede. Aber das ist dann sozusagen auch schon ein bisschen Leermaterial geworden.
So ein bisschen, ja. Und wie gesagt, das waren so die ersten Botnetze, die sich dann so, ja, so weit entwickelt hatten. Das wurde dann eben, wie gesagt, irgendwann ging es dann Richtung Windows-Welt, wo dann einfach die Angreifer gesehen haben, hey, über diese Schwachstellen in Netzwerkdiensten können wir einfach viele Maschinen kompromittieren. Und jetzt wollen wir nicht nur so etwas wie Würmer darauf bringen, sondern wir wollen Bots drauf haben, damit wir eben Kommandos ausführen können. Und das hat sich dann so entwickelt, dass so die ersten Bots aufkamen. Wie gesagt, ganz einfach damals, dass wenn der Angreifer eine Schwachstelle ausgenutzt hat, hat er einen ERC-Client auf die kompromittierte Maschine installiert. Die hat sich dann zu dem ERC-Netz verbunden, hat sich dann noch ein bisschen versteckt auf dem System und dann hat der Angreifer es in den Channel gegangen und konnte Befehle ausschicken.
Genau, das hat man ja vorhin schon erwähnt.
Und das ist natürlich vom Ansatz her ein bisschen blöd, weil einfach der ERC-Kline viel zu groß ist. Deshalb haben die dann irgendwann ihre eigenen ERC-Clients entwickelt, die Programme eben kleiner gemacht, dafür gesorgt, dass die nicht mehr so sichtbar sind auf dem ganzen System. Und dann pushen die einfach nur den Bot auf die komponierten Maschinen und die füllen sie wieder zum ERC-Netz. Das war dann, weiß ich, ein großer Bot. Damals, so 2005, so etwa so, war Argo Bot, war eben quasi ja so Mainstream relativ weit verbreitet. Irgendwann wurde der Sourcecode davon auch verfügbar. SD-Bot ist so ein anderer Bot, der auch sehr weit verbreitet war damals, eben auch weil der Sourcecode verfügbar war. Deshalb konnten wir einfach runterladen, ein bisschen verändern, neu kompilieren, vielleicht noch ein paar neue Funktionen hinzufügen. Und dann konnten die Kiddies quasi anfangen, ihr eigenes Ding zu machen. Weil einfach kommt eine neue Schwachstelle, wird bekannt. Deshalb nimmt man sich den Proof of Concept Exploit, bringt den in den Board rein, fängt dann an, den weiter zu verbreiten lassen. Und dann infiziert man einfach neue Maschinen. Und so wächst das Botnetz dann auch weiter. Weil, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr es schon angesprochen habt, aber so eine Grundmechanismen hinter den Boards ist ja auch, dass die von einer Maschine auf die andere infizieren können. Also sie nutzen Schwachstelle aus. Und dann kopiert der Bot sich selber auf das Zielsystem. Und führt sich dann eben dort aus.
Also die Wurm-Funktionalität sozusagen.
Genau, die Wurm-Funktionalität, genau. Und deshalb, wenn es neue Schwachstellen gab, hat man dann nach ein paar Tagen jeweils auch die passenden Bot-Module quasi gesehen, die dann verintegriert wurden. Und dann waren die Boards wieder einfach schnell am Wachsen. Genau. So Argo-Bot, SD-Bot, so als zwei große.
Wer steckt denn dann letztlich dahinter? Sind wir jetzt immer noch in diesem Because-We-Can und wir zeigen das mal, dass es geht? Oder ist es schon so ein bisschen verschwörerische Teenagerbanden, die einfach Bock drauf haben, irgendwie eBay runterzufahren?
Schon so ein bisschen Banden, ist vielleicht ein bisschen viel, aber schon so kleinere Gruppen von Leuten. Also man fängt an, ArgoBot ist eben so gewesen. Es gab so quasi drei Hauptentwickler. Argo ist so jemand aus Süddeutschland, der dann eben einer so der Hauptentwickler war. Dann gab es Fetty, das ist jemand aus den USA gewesen. Und dann der dritte Entwickler war jemand aus Skandinavien. Das waren so die Leute, die so die Hauptfunktionalität oder die meiste Code quasi beigetragen haben. Da gab es noch ein paar Leute, die kleinere Patches hinzugefügt haben und dafür gesorgt haben. Und dann gab es natürlich so etwas wie Beta-Tester, die quasi getestet haben, wie gut ist der Code denn wirklich in the wild. Oder wenn jetzt eine neue Schwachstelle kam, dass sie das dann auch integriert haben und dann geschaut haben, wie gut kann der Bot sich jetzt weiter verbreiten. Also waren schon so ziemlich professionell, aber eben auch mit einem gemeinsamen System, wo entwickelt wurde und auch Updates.
Aber es klingt für mich immer noch so im Wesentlichen nach technischer Herausforderung, beziehungsweise es einfach geschafft haben.
Genau, die haben jetzt wirklich Geld gemacht damit.
Genau, da stand jetzt noch keine primiakriminelle Absicht dahinter.
Genau, aber das kam dann eben so mehr und mehr, weil als das Source Code dann öffentlich war, haben andere Leute es genommen und dann eben auch angefangen, eben die investierten Maschinen dann auch wie gesagt als Spam-Schleudern zu verwenden und das dann wirklich als Service anzubieten. Oder einfach auch Informationen stehlen von den Maschinen und diese dann verkaufen. Das waren dann eben andere Gruppen, die dann das Ganze ein bisschen professioneller machen und dann auch dadurch wirklich Geld machen mittlerweile.
Für Spam scheinen ja die Botnetze auch immer noch so einen wesentlichen Abwurfplatz zu sagen.
Genau, es gibt da so Studien, die sagen, dass so 80 bis 90 Prozent des Spams einfach nur über Botnetze verschickt wird. Das ist eben so die Hauptplattform, würde ich sagen.
Ja, klingt auch glaubhaft, weil natürlich ist ja nicht so, dass nie versucht wurde, was gegen Spam zu machen. Bloß das konnte halt immer nur so diese großen Quellen ausschalten. Der verschickt viel Mail. Aber wenn jetzt ganz viele Rechner, die ja eigentlich unrelated sind, deren einzige Gemeinsamkeit ist, dass sie halt alle von diesem selben Botnetz übernommen worden sind, die kann man ja nicht auseinanderhalten. Und dann sieht das ja aus wie ganz viele legitime E-Mails.
Ja genau, das ist definitiv ein Problem.
Hm, aber wo befinden wir uns denn jetzt so zeitlich?
Ich würde sagen so 2005, 2006.
Okay, Mitte des letzten Jahrzehnts. Das heißt, da schlug das dann quasi um. Nachdem also die Proof of Concepts da draußen waren, das Ganze im Wesentlichen einfach noch so Hackersport war, oder Crackersport, genau, dass sozusagen das kriminelle Interesse da ran einfach wuchs. Spam ist natürlich erstmal sehr naheliegend. Was gibt es noch so für andere Monetarisierungsmethoden, die so beobachtet wurden?
Ja, das Stehlen von Infos. Oder eben, was sie teilweise machen, ist sowas wie Clickshort.
Ah, Werbenetze.
Genau, Werbenetze und Klicken auf Sachen. Oder was sie teilweise auch gemacht haben, die blenden dann Werbung bei den Maschinen ein und klicken. Also der Nutzerklick drauf oder der Botklick drauf.
Also im Browser wird sozusagen die Werbung ersetzt.
Ja, das ist ja auch eigentlich ganz nett, wenn man auf eine ganz legitime Seite geht und auf einmal Porno-Werbung rechts drin läuft und sowas. Genau, dann muss ich das Stehlen von Infos hat mir schon. DDoS eben, so entweder For Hire auch, ist mir eben sowas auch als Service verkauft.
Du hast ja mal gesagt, du willst hier irgendwie Seite X.
DDoS.
So der digitale Luigi, so hier.
Genau, ist nicht so teuer. Kostet irgendwie, hast du ein paar Tage so eine Studie, 24 Stunden war irgendwie 100 Dollar oder sowas.
100 Dollar? Was kriegt man für 100 Dollar so niedergelegt?
Ich weiß nicht genau, wie viele, vielleicht so ein paar 1000 oder ein paar 100 Maschinen, die dann DDoSen, und das reicht ja hoffentlich schon. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wenn jemand einen Graus-Radio-Server DDoSen würde.
Der DDoS sich schon automatisch, wenn ich Sinn um online stelle, das reicht schon vollkommen aus.
Vielleicht reichen da ja 1000 Maschinen oder 5000.
Da muss man auch gar nicht nachholen.
Ja, was ist das noch? Ja, Clip-Rot, kurz angesprochen, ohne einfach so...
Keelogger hast du ja auch schon ganz am Anfang angesprochen. Das ist dann sicherlich auch ein Ding, dass man dann auch schon in dieses Fishing reingeht. Ist das auch schon ein beobachtetes Phänomen?
Ja, schon. Was sie dann häufig dort eher machen, ist, dass sie die Maschinen so als Proxys benutzen. Fast Flux können wir jetzt auch kurz noch erklären. Da haben wir jetzt ziemlich alle Techniken langsam durch. Fast Flux ist quasi so eine Technik, die heißt das nochmal genau?
Fast Flux. Okay, also Flux.
Die Idee ist, dass das Mapping zwischen einer Domainer und der IP-Adresse einfach sehr schnell wechselt. Typischerweise ist das hier relativ statisch. Die Domäne wird auf eine IP oder vielleicht auf ein Paar, wenn die irgendwie so das per DNS Loadbalancing machen. Die Idee hierbei ist, dass der Angreifer eine Domäne nimmt und die zeigt dann jeweils auf infizierte Maschinen. Auf die infizierten Maschinen läuft eigentlich nur ein Proxy. Deshalb, wenn jetzt eine Anfrage reinkommt, leitet die Maschine das einfach nur weiter an einen anderen Server, das sogenannte Mothership. Dort wird dann eben der ganze Content gehostet und sorgt dann eben dafür, dass man eine robuste Hosting-Infrastruktur hat. Weil es wird einfach alles geproxied über diese infizierten Maschinen und man weiß dann nicht genau, wo steht das Mothership. Und selbst wenn man jetzt hier von den Proxys, also von den infizierten Maschinen ein paar herunternimmt, poppen einfach neue hoch und die werden dann weiter als Proxy benutzt.
Ich habe nicht so ganz verstanden, wer jetzt wen als Proxy benutzt.
Also die Angreifer benutzen die infizierten Maschinen als Proxy.
Um ihre Angriffe durchzuführen.
Genau, und einfach zu verschleiern, wo eigentlich Content gehustet ist. So ein bisschen was, ja. Und klar, ganz normal, dass infizierte Maschinen als Proxy benutzt werden, ist eben auch so eine Standardtechnik, um einfach zu verschleiern, wo der Angreifer genau sitzt. Weil wenn ich das einfach so dreimal proxiere, ist meine Verbindung zwar langsam, aber dann genau herausfinden, wo SARS eigentlich damals der Angreifer ist.
Das ist nahezu unmöglich.
Ja, in der Praxis auf jeden Fall.
So, mit anderen Worten, diese Botnetze versprechen eine Menge Geld, weil man spammen kann man immer noch Geld verdienen. Also manche sagen auch nicht. Ich höre immer mal so das eine, mal das andere. Die Leute klicken ja gar nicht mehr drauf, aber wenn man sich anschaut, wie die Botnetze sich selber so verbreiten, dann mag man das gar nicht mehr so richtig glauben. Also die Leute klicken einfach immer noch auf Scheiße. Und die Computer sind immer noch nicht in der Lage, ihnen ausreichend Unterstützung dabei zu geben, ob das jetzt eine gute Idee ist oder nicht. Ich glaube, so kann man das ganz gut zusammenfassen.
Es gibt auch Leute, die klicken extra auf spammen. Also es gibt ja wirklich Leute, die kaufen so Sachen extra.
Ja, ja. Also ich glaube auch, dass dieses Viagra, das ist einfach auch nachgefragt, sonst würde das da irgendwie auch nicht drinstehen. Es gibt zwar immer wieder so ein paar Angebote, wo ich mich frage, wer will das eigentlich, aber ich frage mich sowieso bei vielen Details dieser Welt, wer das eigentlich so will, und es geht nicht weg dadurch.
Na gut, aber wir haben, wie viele Millionen Leute online sind und wenn einfach 0,001% irgendwas tun, ist es immer noch viel.
So, das heißt, diese Botnetze sind jetzt da draußen. Das haben wir schon relativ ausführlich und auch schon zweimal erläutert eben so diese Organisation über IRC. Vielleicht nochmal kurz auf diese Techniken mit Peer-to-Peer eingehen. Also grundsätzlich geht es ja immer darum, man hat viele installierte Rechner und man möchte jetzt, dass die sich kontrollieren lassen von außen.
Genau.
Und man IRC weglässt, weil sich das relativ gut beobachten lässt, wenn denn mal einer darauf aufmerksam geworden ist. In dem Moment ist es ja dann auch ein großes Sicherheitsrisiko für den Angreifer. Dann werden Peer-to-Peer-Methoden angewendet.
Vielleicht noch so als Zwischenschritt. Was die Angreifer häufig mittlerweile auch machen, oder so eine Standardtechnik, ist eben das Ganze über HTTP zu machen. Es gibt einfach in der Mitte so einen HTTP-Server und die Bots wissen einfach, wohin sie ihre HTTP-Verbindung oder Anfragen schicken müssen. Und als Rückgabewert bekommen sie dann das aktuelle Kommando, was gemacht wird. Hat eben aus Angreifer-Sicht den Vorteil, dass HTTP-Anfragen eigentlich überall durchgehen. Selbst wenn man einen Proxy zwischendrin hat. Und Port 80 ist ja so das Loch in der Firewall eigentlich. Und dann gibt es einfach einen zentralen HTTP-Server, über den das gleiche läuft. Das ist nicht ihr Ziel, sondern HTTP. Oder eben teilweise nutzen eben auch ihre eigenen proprietären Protokolle.
Aber ist das nicht so ein bisschen verrätterisch, weil dann müssen ja bisher in allen Clients entweder eine IP-Adresse oder so ein DNS-Name drinstehen, um den dann auch zu finden.
Ja, das schon, ja klar. Also da hat man eigentlich so diesen Single Point of Failure. Es gibt eben in der Mitte so einen CNC, also Command & Control Server. Und wenn der weg ist, dann hat der Angreifer einfach keine Kontrolle mehr, weil er einfach keine Befehle mehr schicken kann. Deshalb macht das Angreifer sich eigentlich Sinn, eben so eine peer-to-peer Infrastruktur aufzubauen, dass eben die infizierten Maschinen sowohl Client als auch Server sind. Sodass man dort eben, selbst wenn man ein paar von den Maschinen offline nimmt, hat man immer noch genug Maschinen, die immer noch zum Weiterverbreiten des Kommandos benutzt werden können.
Aber ich meine, auch peer-to-peer kommt jetzt nicht vollständig ohne zentrale Instanz aus. Die müssen sich ja auch erstmal irgendwie finden. Wie läuft das normalerweise?
Was ich bei Storm, Stormwarm, war eben so der große peer-to-peer-Bot 2007, 2008. Was die dort hatten in der ersten Version war sowas wie, dass sie ein existierendes peer-to-peer-Netz hijacken. Die benutzen eine DHT, Dishydrate Taste Table. Konkret war das Kademlia. Und haben ein existierendes Netz dort als Parasit benutzt. Einstiegspunkte waren teilweise legitime Server im Netz. Die Bots waren dann neben den legitimen Maschinen einfach online. Und die Bots wussten einfach, unter welchem Key sie suchen mussten. Wo es einfach die aktuellen Kommandos gab.
Das heißt, ein DHT-Netz braucht ja, wie nennt man den nochmal gleich? Super Notes oder? Ich weiß jetzt gerade nicht genau, wie der Termin ist.
Ja, je nachdem, was für ein Smartphone.
Also halt die Rechner, an die man sich erst mal wendet, um überhaupt erst mal irgendeine Information zu bekommen, ist ja wie bei, also irgendwas muss man ja wissen. Ist ja auch bei DNS so, man muss erst mal einen DNS-Server kennen, sonst kann man eben keine einzige Adresse auflösen. Und genauso ist das natürlich auch bei BitTorrent, auch wenn man distributed Taste Table verwendet. Also selbst wenn man nicht über einen zentralen Trecker geht, irgendwo muss man ja überhaupt erst mal jemanden finden, der weiß, wovon man redet. Weil es gibt einfach sonst ein bisschen zu viele Rechner mit zu viel Realitätsbildern im Internet. So, das heißt deren Methode war sozusagen, dass sie einfach was anderes nehmen, was sowieso schon da ist, was insofern dann auch nicht auffällig ist. Und dieses Netz übernimmt dann für die Botnetze quasi die Vermittlung, ohne das zu wissen. Weil die keine Ahnung haben, was diese Kleins eigentlich wollen. Das sind ja Vermittlungsknoten auf einer sehr minimalen Ebene, die eigentlich nichts anderes machen, als ein paar IP-Adressen weiterzureichen. Das ist auch irgendwie nicht steuerbar. Und man kann es halt auch nicht legitim runterfahren, weil so funktioniert sowas halt nun mal. Und es geht auch nicht so sehr viel anders, das zu merken.
Oder jetzt eben Whaledeck. Das war jetzt so das aktuelle P2P-Netz letztes Jahr. Dort war es eben so, die haben dann eben Domains als Einstiegspunkt benutzt. Also der Bot kannte eben die Domäne. Die haben dann auch wieder Fast Flags als Technik benutzt. Also sprich, diese Domäne hat jeweils auf aktive Bots gezeigt. Deshalb der Bot, wenn er jetzt online gekommen ist, konnte einfach DNS-Abfrage machen. Und hat dann eben Einstiegspunkte ins Netz gefunden. Und konnte dann diese kontaktieren. Und von dort hat er dann aktuelle Peer-Listen bekommen.
Aber dadurch müssten sie ja dann eigentlich die... So ein DNS, das bedeutet ja, dass dieser DNS-Eintrag unter direkter Kontrolle des Bösen ist. Und so ein DNS-Rekord ist ja dann sozusagen... Also so ein Domain hat ja auch einen Halter.
Ist das dann nicht sozusagen... Ja, das kann ja perfekt sein. Also jetzt bei Whale Deck waren das jeweils registriert unter irgendwelchen chinesischen Namen. Und es ist die Frage, ob das... Also ich glaube nicht, dass die ihren realen Namen dort angeben. War alles registriert über VeriSign. Also alles dort kommen. So um die 270 Stück gab es. Die, die die jeweils benutzt haben, jetzt über die verschiedene Monate. Und das waren dann jeweils, ja, jetzt kommen, glaube ich, 22 verschiedene Fake-Identitäten wahrscheinlich.
Also der Aufwand muss schon getrieben werden, aber naja, da denkt man sich halt was aus.
Genau.
Und so kriegt man heutzutage auch den Domain. Wird nicht mehr lange dauern, und dann geht es echt nur noch mit Führerschein und Tralala, ne?
Ich glaube, China ist mittlerweile sogar so weit. Muss man, glaube ich, wirklich dort hingehen und personalausweis-zeigen und so. Ich hoffe, dass wir in Deutschland das nie so schnell bekommen.
Wobei man jetzt, wenn es wirklich eine chinesische Domäne ist, wahrscheinlich auch nicht unbedingt so viel Kooperation erwarten darf, oder?
Ja, das ist generell auch so eins der Probleme. Vielleicht genau passt die gut in den Kontext eigentlich. Weil es so bei den Bots ist ja so, die Opfer sind irgendwie weltweit verteilt. Gibt es, was ich, 50.000 Opfer weltweit, in verschiedenen Ländern. Dann steht der Kommandoserver, meinetwegen in den USA. Der Angreifer sitzt eigentlich, sagen wir jetzt mal, irgendwo im Ostblock. Der benutzt einfach ein Proxy, der in Deutschland steht. Und schickt daraus die Befehle raus.
Das heißt nicht mehr Ostblock.
Ein ehemaliger Ostblock. Das stimmt.
Ost-Europa sagt man heutzutage.
Ja, stimmt. Als Polizist habe ich es eben echt schwierig. Weil jetzt kommt einfach jemand zu mir und sagt, mein Rechner ist infiziert. Der typische Polizist wird sagen, okay, kümmer ich mich später drum wahrscheinlich. Aber selbst wenn die jetzt etwas tun wollen, ist es eben schwierig, weil die brauchen eben die internationale Zusammenarbeit. Das ist eben schwierig. In Ländern wie China gibt es eben teilweise nicht so gut die Kooperationsbereitschaft. Auch im Osteuropa ist das teilweise auch ein bisschen schwieriger. Aber selbst auch hier in Deutschland ist es teilweise schwierig, dass man eben wirklich kooperative Leute findet. Und eben dadurch, dass das grenzübergreifend ist, macht das Ganze eben auch viel.
Was ist das Hauptproblem? Ist es die Kooperationswürdigkeit oder die Kompetenz oder beides?
Ich würde sagen beides. Weil zum einen ist es eben schwierig, man muss aus verschiedenen Ländern jeweils auch die Informationen bekommen, damit man das gut korrelieren kann. Es gibt definitiv sehr kompetente Polizisten, nur leider zu wenig. Wenn ich mir vorstelle, jemand, der echt sehr gut ist, will der wirklich im öffentlichen Dienst arbeiten.
Das ist definitiv ein Problem, was sie wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht anders lösen lässt als durch Geld. Jetzt hast du schon mal gesagt, bei diesen Botnetzen, die du bisher erwähnt hast, das war halt dann und dann. Das heißt, die kamen und sie gingen auch wieder. Diesen Stormworm gibt es so nicht mehr.
Wodurch ist der dann niedergerungen worden? Der war knapp anderthalb Jahre, ein bisschen weniger. Der war etwa online, hat sich vielleicht ein paar Milliarden Spam-Mails wahrscheinlich verschickt. Da gab es immer konzentrierte Aktionen dagegen. Der lustige Aspekt in P2P-Netzen ist ja, dass wenn ich einmal das Protokoll verstanden habe, kann ich ja auch anfangen, damit rumzuspielen. Das Scrawling hatte ich ja schon mal erklärt, dass ich mir einen guten Überblick verschaffen kann, welche Bots sind gerade online, was machen die gerade. Zählen kann ich einigermaßen gut. Nur dann kann ich ja auch anfangen, Störnachrichten reinzuschicken.
Benutzen diese Netze selber keine Krypto? Ich meine, wenn ich jetzt so etwas bauen würde, würde ich ja mir als erstes keinerlei Befehle geben lassen, die nicht selbst noch mit irgendeinem Schlüssel verschlüsselt sind.
Das schon, die nutzen teilweise Krypto, teilweise machen die Krypto ein bisschen falsch. Die nutzen ein symmetrisches Verfahren, die Schlüssel gibt es in Beinung selber. Bei Peer-to-Peer-Netzen ist es ja so, wenn ich jetzt etwas suche, hangele ich mich durch das Netz durch. Wenn ich irgendwo hin will, muss ich einige Peers kontaktieren. Darüber finde ich dann den Content, den ich haben will. Was ich jetzt als Gegenspieler versuchen kann, ist, mich um diesen gesuchten Content rumzubringen.
Was machst du denn jetzt für einen Content?
Der Befehl. Der Bot muss hier irgendwo nachschauen, was ist der aktuelle Befehl. Er muss hier irgendwie suchen. Es gibt irgendwo einen Key innerhalb dieses Content.
Er muss erst mal jemanden finden, der ihm Befehle geben darf.
Was ich jetzt eben als Verteidiger versuchen kann, ist, dass ich meine Peers, also meine Verteidiger, um diesen Kommandogeber rumstelle. Und dann quasi den Isoliere, sowas kann man versuchen.
Ah, das heißt?
Also man macht so Angriffe gegen das Peer-to-Peer-Netz, dass man eben versucht oder...
Ah, dass du sozusagen nur Adressen rausgibst, die nicht den anderen Greifer mit einschließen.
Genau so was, ja. Oder dass ich irgendwie versuche, Nachrichten in das Peer-to-Peer-Netz reinzuschicken, dass diese Legitimen oder diese Befehle, die dort quasi vom Angreifer hinterlegt wurden, dass man die überschreiben will oder sowas. So was kann man versuchen.
Da stellt sich jetzt die Frage, wie überhaupt diese Kommandostruktur aussieht. Also was für eine Komplexität an Kommandos haben die? Also kann man da sozusagen auch Peers rausnehmen und sagen, hier, den jetzt nicht mehr berücksichtigen?
Ja, das geht teilweise. Kommt auf die konkrete Implementierung an. Beispielsweise bei Whaledeck ist es so, was man da machen konnte, ist, ich schicke dem Bot quasi eine Peer-Liste und sage ihm hier, hey, das ist die neue Peer-Liste. Der fragt bei mir an, ich gebe ihm das Ergebnis zurück. Da schreibe ich dann nur ein Peer-Liste unter meiner Kontrolle hin. So 200 Stück. Der nimmt die dann ohne groß checken. Dann kennt der auf einmal nur noch mich und keinen anderen Bots mehr. Ich überschreibe dem quasi seine Peer-Liste. Dann kennt der nur noch mich. Das ist dann natürlich...
Dann kann man sozusagen das Netz übernehmen.
Wenn man dann legal, muss man natürlich sehr, sehr... Eine Linie zwischen schwarz und weiß oder irgendwo im grauen Bereich ist. Wir schicken ja keine Kommandos ins Netz rein. Wir führen ja keinen Code auf fremde Maschinen aus. Aber...
Du hast schon so ein bisschen die Lizenz zum Töten.
So ein 007-Effekt. Nicht so ganz, hoffe ich mal. Wir reden auch schon mit Juristen. Ist immer so ein bisschen schwierig. Kann ich mir das vorstellen. Aber wir versuchen trotzdem, auf der weißen Seite zu bleiben. Also rechtlich ist das natürlich immer das Problem. Es ist klar. Eine dünne Linie zwischen beiden Seiten.
Ja klar. Wir versuchen das jetzt noch mal ein bisschen zusammenzufassen. Diese Botnetze setzen sich auf. Die infizieren auf welche Methoden auch immer. Durch verschickte E-Mails oder durch angegriffene Webbrowser. Oder keine Ahnung. Schaffen sie es einfach, mehr oder weniger identischen Code auf diesen ganzen Rechnern zu bringen. Und die sind in der Lage, sich entweder mit einem zentralen Kommandogäber oder einer, der sich aus so einer peer-to-peer-Vernetzungsstruktur gibt, zu verbinden. Und erkennen den dann sozusagen als ihren Herren an. Und lassen sich eben sagen, was sie machen. Jetzt gibt es irgendwie eine Reihe von Kommandos, die diese Bot-Klines, oder wie man sie nennen soll, verstehen. So, was sie dann halt tun können. Andere Maschinen angreifen, E-Mails verschicken, etc. Das dürfte ja auch relativ high-level sein an der Stelle. Oder gibt es auch schon so Botnetze, die eigentlich nur noch Java vor Ems sind, wo man dann einen beliebigen Code rein drücken kann. Aber das wäre dann im Prinzip so die nächste Bedrohungsstufe, oder? Dass man die Maschinen dann eigentlich komplett übernehmen kann und dann noch, was weiß ich, ganze Betriebssysteme reinladen kann. Ja, das ist jetzt nicht, was das verhindern sollte. Aber derzeit sind sie sozusagen noch klein und dediziert und was auch immer. So, das heißt, was ihr jetzt quasi als Security-Forscher macht, ist ja auch herauszufinden, okay, erst mal, also erst mal müsst ihr die ja finden. Erst mal müsst ihr ja überhaupt erst mal wissen, dass es die gibt.
Genau, ja.
Wie stößt man da drauf?
Da benutzen wir ein Konzept namens Honeypots, also so Honigstöpfe oder so. Kann man sich so vorstellen als elektronische Köder. Also quasi ich habe ein Computersystem, dass ich einfach so aufsetze, dass es unsicher ist. Also ich installiere vielleicht nicht alle Patches oder mache nicht alles Sicherheitsupdates, alles Mögliche. Installiere allerdings etwas Zusatzsoftware, die einfach dafür sorgt, dass mitgeschnitten wird, was auf dem System passiert. Und verbinde dann diese Maschine mit dem Netz und schaue dann einfach, wie wird die angegriffen.
Also so ein bisschen das Äquivalent zu Auto am Straßenrand mit dampfender Motorhaube, wo dann so eine junge Dame leicht begleitet mit Beinen nach vorne gestrickt rumsteht und sagt, hilf mir.
Genau so. So ähnlich. Oder einfach das Auto nicht abgeschlossen.
Und ihr seid dahinter im Busch und wartet.
Wartet und guckt, was passiert hier. Und wenn der Angreifer jetzt eben diese Maschine kompromittiert, sieht man zum einen eben, wie greift er mich überhaupt an? Was macht er auf der Maschine? Welche Tools lädt er nach? Wie geht er vor? Vielleicht, wie kompensiert er mit anderen Leuten, nachdem er meinen Honeypot kompromittiert hat? Und vielleicht, was will der Angreifer überhaupt? Muss ich so als Aquarium vorstellen.
Aber wie merkt ihr denn überhaupt, dass ihr infiziert worden seid?
Da hilft dann diese Logging-Software. Die schneidet dann eben mit, was passiert. Und eigentlich eidelt das System mehr die ganze Zeit, weil wir machen ja nichts. Und wenn das System dann irgendwann Systemaktivität zeigt, sieht man, okay, da passiert gerade was.
Und wie viele Honig-Töpfe habt ihr da draußen stehen?
Also es gibt so verschiedene Arten von Honig-Töpfen. Wir hatten damals in Aachen zum Beispiel eine sehr große Installation. Da hatten wir vom Rechenzentrum jetzt so etwa 30.000 oder 32.000 IPs bekommen. Das war einfach ein schönes, großes Netz. Die haben alle jeweils auf eine physische Maschine gequotet worden.
Sah aus wie viele Rechner, aber war eigentlich nur einer.
Und dann eben so teilweise verteilt. Im Moment in Bochum bauen wir das gerade noch auf. In Wien haben wir so ein paar laufen. Oder in Mannheim dort auch.
Und reicht es einfach nur da zu sein, IP-Adressen abzudecken und zu warten? Und irgendwann kommt dann schon einer? Oder muss man sich irgendwie im Netz auch bekannt machen?
Es gibt verschiedene Arten von Ansätzen. Was ich jetzt so erkläre, waren eher Server-basierte Honeypots. Die bieten also Netzwerksdienste an und warten dann auf Angriffe dagegen. Das hat eben so 2005 super funktioniert, weil dort gab es die ganzen Angriffe gegen diese RPC-Dienste zum Beispiel. Oder wenn man heutzutage eine Web-Anwendung aufsetzt, irgendwas kaputten PHP kaut, kann man auch ziemlich sicher sein, dass man innerhalb von ein paar Tagen kompromittiert wird. Das ist aber so, man wartet auf Angreifer. Das ist eben so ein bisschen Glückssache. Was passiert? Passiert, du hab was. Passiert, was Interessantes. Ich muss mir mal schauen, wo setzt man das genau auf? Meinetwegen, wenn ich jetzt im Uninetz bin, sehe ich wahrscheinlich eine andere Art von Angriffen, als wenn ich das auf einer DSL-Anschluss mache. Oder wenn ich jetzt in einem Behördennetz wäre oder im Bundeswehrnetz oder so, sehe ich bestimmt auch eine andere Art von Angriffen dort. Und eine andere Qualität von Angriffen. Gut, also das gibt es diese Server-Sachen, Server-Honeypots. Und dann gibt es eben diese kleinen Honeypots. Da ist eher die Idee, ich verhalte mich wie ein dummer User. Also ich klicke auf alles Mögliche drauf, surf auf jede Webseite, klicke da überall drauf, öffne alle E-Mail-Attachments und so. Verhalte mich also genauso, wie ich mich nicht verhalten sollte. Und da finde ich dann eben die bösen Webseiten.
Da gehe ich wirklich raus ins Netz.
Automatisiert. Die Software, die surft automatisiert. Oder analysiert automatisiert den Spam.
Folgt einfach irgendwelchen Links, klässt immer wieder andere Webseiten.
Genau, dann 20 Tabs parallel, damit man das geparalysieren kann.
Und dann kommt schon irgendwann einer auf die Idee, einem irgendwie Bösenkot unterzuschmeißen.
Genau. Wenn man richtig Inputs, also richtig URL-Feed hat, geht das nach 2-3 Minuten. Dass man die erste Seite findet, die... Man muss hier nur... Also, wenn man gute Input URL hat, klar, das geht einfach ganz schnell.
Ich habe mal so ein böses Gerücht gehört, dass es irgendwie nur wenige Minuten dauert für den durchschnittlichen Windows-Benutzer mit ohne nennenswertem Schutz, bevor der sich irgendwas eingefunken hat. Hältst du das für realistisch?
Ja, das war früher mal so. Ich denke, mittlerweile, ich denke, wenn ich ein Windows 7 oder ein Vista aufsetze, hat das, glaube ich, per Default auch die Firewall. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es die per Default anhat. Ich glaube nicht. Aber die ganzen Per Default hat es einfach nicht mehr, so viele Schwachstellen. Also früher, wenn ich jetzt...
Außer Flash.
Ja, aber da muss ich ja irgendwas interagieren damit. Also früher war es eher so, dass wenn die noch Port 135 und 445 offen hatten und eben ohne Patch, dann ist es eben relativ schnell eingekommen.
Okay, also diese Aussage bezog sich sozusagen wesentlichen auf die alten Windows mit ihren ohnehin offenen Diensten, die dann eben angegriffen werden. Aber jetzt sozusagen, wenn man ein relativ dichtes Windows 7 hat und jetzt mal im Browser losmarschiert, also sozusagen sich im Internet was einzutreten, wenn man diesen Methoden folgt, du sagst jetzt zwei bis drei Minuten, wie viele URLs muss man da folgen?
Ja, da benutze ich ja auch einen ungepatchten Browser. Also benutze ich extra den EE6.
Ja, das ist mir schon bewusst, aber wie viel lauert sozusagen auf einen, wenn man ungeschützt durch den Datenwald zieht?
Ob es da gute Zahlen zu gibt, weiß ich nicht, aber...
Na gut, aber du sagst ja, zwei bis drei Minuten dauert das.
Genau, aber da geben wir ja auch die zielten URLs rein, von denen wir denken, die sind eventuell böse.
Ah, okay, gut. Und wo kriegt ihr die her?
Das ist so ein bisschen Teil der Magic, dass man, was ich aus Spare-Mails sich das nimmt, da ist aber nur so, was ich so zwei, drei Prozent links, sind dort böse nur. Oder man sucht eben, was im Moment relativ populär ist, dass man so dieses Search Engine Optimization machen, die Angreifer, dass sie einfach so die aktuellen Google-Trends zum Beispiel, wenn man danach googelt, findet man in den Top 100 Seiten häufig eben auch irgendwelche bösen Seiten. Weil die Angreifer eben dafür sorgen, dass ihre bösartigen Seiten zu den aktuellen Google-Trends passen, und deshalb kriegen sie dann dort rüber Leute. Also wenn man da eben weiß, wie man quasi, oder wo die Angreifer lauern, kann man entsprechend sich eben verhalten und dort eben OALt gehen.
Also was weiß ich, zur Wahl des Bundespräsidenten, wollte ich gerade sagen, des amerikanischen Präsidenten, irgendwie Obama.
Genau, oder ich denke im Moment, wenn man nach der Ölkatastrophe sucht, findet man, mit den Top 100 Google-Resultaten bestimmt auch vielleicht 3, 4, 5, 6 bösartige Seiten.
Verstehe, okay, gut. Das heißt, damit fittert ihr eure automatisierten Klickmaschinen, die klicken dann irgendwie los und treten sich dann auch schnell eine Mine ein.
Genau. Und das genau Mine eintreten ist ja dann interessant, weil da sehen wir dann genau den Angriff. Und wo man dann eben sieht, okay, welches Schadstoff wäre, will der Angriff jetzt bei uns installieren, das kann man dann automatisch auch wieder rausziehen und haben dann wieder eine neue Binär-Datei für uns.
Und habt ihr da irgendwie so eine rote Lampe mit Sirene, die dann bei euch im Raum losgeht, wenn sowas passiert ist? Oder passiert das so häufig, dass ihr dann irgendwie nur noch Ohrenschmerzen bekommen werdet?
Wir wollten immer diese Lampe haben. Da hat es nie ganz gepasst.
Da hab ich jetzt irgendwann einen Schmerz ausgelöst. Wie häufig passiert das dann so am Tag, dass man sich was einfängt über diese Methode?
Hunderte Male.
Hunderte Male, das wäre auch ein bisschen laut, oder?
Ja, und vor allem Dauersound ist das auch doof. Und was wir auch noch haben wollen, ist so die große rote Buzzer, wo man dann draufdrückt.
Rutschstangen wären auch noch ganz gut. Einsatz, ab in den Serverraum und in den roten Rutschen. Genau, das macht sich gut, wenn die Presse kommt. Die sind bestimmt mächtig beeindruckt. Hier haben wir unsere Maschine mit dem Bing. Und hier ist der rote Buzzer. Wenn man da draufdrückt, geht das Internet aus.
Sehr schön, ja. Aber wie gesagt, insgesamt helfen uns die Honeypots einfach automatisiert, neue Exemplare von der Scharztoffe zu finden.
Das heißt, es ist für wirklich populäre Botnetze gar nicht so einfach, nicht aufzufallen, weil die wollen ja überall rein. Und deswegen laufen sie eigentlich auch zwangsläufig da auf.
Bei uns auch, ja genau.
Okay, gut. Dann müsst ihr aber ja überhaupt schnell charakterisieren, ist das etwas, was wir kennen oder nicht? Oder ist es hier irgendwie was Neues?
Genau.
Wie viele unterschiedliche Botnetze muss man sich denn da draußen so vorstellen?
Das ist auch schwierig zu sagen. Klar, die großen Botnetze, die findet man einfach. Weil, wie du gerade meintest, die wollen ja weiter verbreiten. Und deshalb, die kann man relativ schnell finden. Es ist natürlich die Frage, wie jetzt die komplette Verteilung ist. Also wie viele von diesen ganz kleinen Botnetzen gibt es? Die, weiß ich, nur 500 Maschinen infiziert haben. Und das ist eben eine sehr, sehr große Grauzone, glaube ich. Deshalb, wie viele Botnetze es gibt? Ich würde sagen einige hundert, einige tausend. Vielleicht zehntausend, vielleicht ein paar mehr noch. Vielleicht noch mehr, keine Ahnung. Aber das zu zählen ist schwierig. Weil einfach, erst die Frage, was ist alles unter der Schwelle, was wir gar nicht sehen oder was auch andere nicht sehen. Was ich jetzt von der Zeit, jetzt Ghostnet war so eine große Schlagzeile. Da wurde ein Botnetz gefunden, hatte nur so um die 1200, 1300 infizierte Maschinen. Allerdings waren die alle in irgendwelchen Behördennetzen, Regierungsnetzen oder in irgendwelchen Botschaften. Und das natürlich dann, ja klar, sind nur wenig Maschinen. Allerdings natürlich sehr sensitiv, weil die einfach in sehr sensitiven Netzen laufen.
Warum war das so? Weil die die explizit danach ausgesucht haben? Und woran konnten die das? Also die haben sozusagen nur bestimmte IP-Ranges, von denen sie wussten, etc.
das war wahrscheinlich eher per Mail und mit Attachment. Und dann die sie die Angriffe. Oder Aurora hatten wir ja schon angesprochen. Das waren ja auch gezielte Angriffe gegen Firmen. Und sowas eben zu finden, ist für uns schwierig. Darum haben wir keine Einsicht rein, wirklich.
Verstehe, weil die einfach nicht so schnell bei den Honeypots aufschlagen. Das heißt eigentlich müsste man, habt ihr auch schon mal darüber nachgedacht, dann sozusagen auch gezielt bei solchen Behörden, etc. Honeypots aufzustellen?
Ja, Zusammenarbeit dort ist schwierig.
Kann ich mir vorstellen, das ist natürlich auch eine Vertrauensfrage.
Klar, also wenn die Bundeswehr jetzt kommen würde, was ich so nicht mit denen zusammenarbeiten will, aber ich glaube nicht, dass die einfach so Informationen rausgeben können, weil das ist ja irgendwie auch...
Naja, das ist ein Dilemma. Andererseits müssen sie es dann halt selber betreiben, aber das ist natürlich ein komplexes Spielchen. Aber bleiben wir ruhig noch mal so ein bisschen bei diesem, wie findet man sie und was tut man dann danach? Also was ist denn jetzt mal so ein Netz, was ihr auch besonders auseinandergenommen habt, wo ihr irgendwie besonders engagiert wart? Oder wo du jetzt besonders engagiert warst?
Was in verschiedenen Gruppen? Also Storm und Whaledeck war einfach interessant, weil es die P2P-Netze waren. Und sonst diese IAC, HTTP haben wir viele gemacht. Die haben dann typisch keinen dedizierten Namen, weil es einfach zu viele davon gibt. Also interessant waren auf jeden Fall diese P2P-Netze, weil die so als Spielgrund quasi auch ganz nett waren.
Ja, da gehört aber jetzt diese Aurora- und Großnetzgeschichte nicht dazu.
Nee, nee, das haben andere Leute.
Und dieser Conficker?
Conficker habe ich selbst eigentlich wenig zugemacht. Ist das auch so ein P2P-Ding? Nee, das ist eher nur ein klassischer Wurm. Da gibt es auch so diese Kommandostruktur. Conficker haben die Leute von der Uni Bonn sehr gute Arbeit gemacht. Da gibt es eben sehr detaillierte Analysen von denen und sehr gute Einblicke.
Da können wir vielleicht noch mal drauf kommen. Aber bleiben wir doch mal kurz bei denen, die du jetzt genau gemacht hast. Also Storm und Raildeck. Die sind ja nun auch beide ausgeschaltet worden. Das sind wahrscheinlich sehr unterschiedliche Geschichten. Na, wie war denn das bei Storm? Also wann habt ihr denn ihn das erste Mal entdeckt? Und wann wurde da beschlossen, also wem da was gegen zu tun?
Wir haben eben so Zugriff auf einige große Spam-Traps, dass wir Spam automatisch sammeln können. Und wenn ich da mal zurückgegangen bin, war, glaube ich, so Mitte Dezember 2006, wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe. So die erste quasi Spam-Mail mit Attachment. Ich glaube, da ging es auch schon in Richtung Christmas-Card oder sowas, wo dann eben das Attachment an die Mail quasi ein Binary von Storm war. So Dezember 2006 ging es da los.
Christmas-Card?
Christmas-Card. Storm Worm hat den Namen eigentlich bekommen, damals das Orkan Tief, das war im Februar 2007, glaube ich, hier in Europa. Da haben die Angreifer dann eben auch so eine Spam-Kampagne herausgeschickt, wo es dann eben der Titel war so Storm Hit Europe oder sowas. Und so hat sich dann der Name quasi durchgesetzt.
Verstehe.
Hat eben im Februar oder März den Namen bekommen, wurde dann im Sommer eben relativ groß. Die Angreifer, was sie eben zur Weiterverbreitung haben, die nur Spam-Mails benutzt, jeweils Social Engineering. Und die haben es dann echt gut gemacht, dass sie jeweils, wenn aktuelle Ereignisse waren, haben die Mails rausgeschickt, die dann jeweils dazu gepasst haben. Wenn es irgendwelche Feiertage gab, haben die jetzt hier dazu Mails geschickt. Zum Beispiel zu Halloween gab es dann extra Mails oder zu Weihnachten oder Silvester, wo dann jeweils das jeweils gepasst hat, einfach gut zu dem aktuellen Kontext. Und dann eben auch sowas wie freie Spiele oder die Kurskarten, was eben auch so immer zwischendurch gemacht wurde. Dann haben wir und auch viele andere Forscher einfach, fanden das ganz spannend. Konkret war es eben damals, wie an der Uni Mannheim, dann Leute von Georgia Tech, das ist in Atlanta, oder auch die Universität in Kalifornien in San Diego. Das waren so die drei großen akademischen Gruppen, die da viel gemacht haben. Das ist eigentlich ganz lustig, wenn man so das P2P-Netz so crawlt und beobachtet und sieht dann dauernd auch die Aktivität von den anderen Forschergruppen, die dann auch Content reinbringen und so.
Wie tauscht man sich denn da darüber aus?
Also wir kennen, also ich kenne die Forscher von dort eben auch. Wir haben das dann per Mail gemacht, wo uns auch ein bisschen abgestimmt haben, wer darf denn jetzt mal rumspielen oder sowas. Da gibt es dann eben schon Kanäle oder gibt ihm jede Menge Security-Mailing-Listen, wo man sich so oder so was austauschen kann.
Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo das irgendwie erkannt ist, ist dann auch relativ schnell klar, wird auch sofort Alarm geschlagen. Das hält man nicht lange bei sich.
Genau, Storm, wie gesagt, haben wir dann viel gemacht, das Netz studiert oder auch Gegenmaßnahmen probiert, welche Art von Stör-Traffic kann ich in das Netz reinschicken, um das zu stoppen, so richtig abgeschaltet, wo das dann andere Leute gemacht haben. Da waren die Jungs hinter das Spam-Haus relativ aktiv, die dann dafür gesorgt haben. Aber es gab eben noch einige zentrale Server in dem ganzen Netz, die einfach die Angreifer benutzt haben, um dann zum Beispiel dort die Spam-Mails vor Reddit zu halten. Oder wenn Informationen von den Bots gestohlen wurden, also von den infizierten Maschinen gestohlen wurden, dass die eben dort auch an diese Backend-Server geschickt wurden konnten. Die wurden eben abgeschaltet. Und dann hat Microsoft auch viel getan. Einfach dieses Malicious Software Removal Tool, MSRT, das ist einfach dort eine entsprechende Basis Virenschutz für Windows. Dass sie dort entsprechende Signaturen entwickelt haben. Oder die Antivirenindustrie hat viel gemacht. Und so hat Stormler über die Zeit einfach an Bedeutung verloren.
Das heißt, über diese MSRT und Antiviren-Tools konnte dann tatsächlich auch nachträglich quasi Hilfestellung gegeben werden. Nach dem Motto hier, guck doch mal, ob auf deinem Rechner das und das ist. Mit der Signatur. Und dann wurde es auch entfernt. Und das Botnetz war nicht in der Lage, sich schneller zu verbreiten, als es entfernt wurde?
Ja, nicht ganz. Also hat man immer so schöne Kurven gesehen. Wenn die eine neue Kampagne haben, ging es hoch. Dann gab es so das MSNT-Update für die neuen Binary Things wieder runter. Das waren so schöne Kurvenbewegungen über die Zeit. Aber generell gab es dann eben auch andere Leute, die Stör-Traffic in das Netz geschickt haben und auch dafür gesorgt haben, dass die Backend-Server runtergefahren wurden. Und dann hat es einigermaßen, also wurde das Netz eher bedeutungslos.
Aber wer engagiert sich denn dann sozusagen in so einer Tätigkeit? Ich meine, man muss ja auch mal Geld verdienen, jetzt andere Leute Maschinen von Botnetzen zu befreien. Gibt es da einen Auftraggeber oder ist das einfach für Rom und Ehre?
Also es gibt eben eine Gruppe, Shadow-Server, die machen das für Rom und Ehre vor allem. Oder ich mache es für Rom und Ehre, definitiv. Es ist so eine Gruppe von Security-Spezialisten, würde ich mal sagen, die sich jetzt jahrelang schon mit dem ganzen Thema beschäftigen, viel automatisiert haben, für die Botnetze zu finden, zu beobachten und dann auch abzuschalten. Das sind so Freiwillige, die das so aus Spaß machen vor allem. Und dann gibt es ja diese Zerts, also Computer Emergency Response Teams. Das sind jeweils, die werden irgendwie bezahlt, entweder von großen Firmen oder auch von Regierungen, was weiß ich.
Universitäten für auch?
Unis zum Beispiel, ja. Vielleicht kann man sich vorstellen, hier in Deutschland gibt es zum Beispiel Siemens Zert. Also die sind dann für Siemens die Security-Vorfälle zuständig. Die Telekom hat einen Zert. Es gibt allerdings auch sowas wie Zertbund. Die kümmern sich dann um die Sicherheit in den Behördennetzen. Oder DFN Zert, die kümmern sich dann um die Sicherheit im ganzen DFN, also deutschen Forschungsnetz. Das sind einfach so Teams von Leuten.
So ein bisschen die Betriebsfeuer werden.
Genau. Und die arbeiten eben auch in diesem Bereich und schauen eben, was kann man dagegen tun und das ist ja auch so Teil ihrer Aufgabe.
Das heißt, die kollektive Aktivität all dieser Zerts, Shadow-Server und sonstiger Experten hat dann sozusagen über die Zeit tatsächlich dazu bewirkt, dass das Stormnetz so schwach wurde, dass es nicht mehr in der Lage war, sich auch wieder selber hochzuziehen?
Ja, und die Angreifer, die waren dann eine Zeit lang eben nicht aktiv, haben nichts mehr gemacht, richtig, an der Weiterentwicklung. Und dann kam so im Dezember 2008, genau 2008, kam dann eine Whale Deck, das ist quasi so der Nachfolger. Wenn man sich dann so die beiden Botnets anschaut, gibt es dann viele Indizien, die dafür sprechen, dass eigentlich die gleiche Gruppe dahinter steckt.
Das heißt, die haben sozusagen gesehen, diesen Kampf können wir jetzt so nicht gewinnen, bzw. um ihn zu gewinnen, müssen wir viele Dinge tun, wo es besser wäre, einfach etwas komplett auf eine neue technische Basis zu stellen.
Genau, und das war dann, also viele Grundkonzepte gab es immer noch, die sind eigentlich ziemlich gleich, beispielsweise die Art, wie die Spam-Mails konstruiert werden und verschickt werden, ist eins zu eins. Es gibt noch ein paar weitere Indizien dafür, dass eigentlich die gleiche Gruppe dahintersteckt. Und dann, wie gesagt, Dezember 2008 ging es mit Raildeck los, weil dann 2009 hatte der dann so seine Hochzeit. Es gab dann wieder eine Gruppe, die sich das genau angeschaut haben und überlegt haben, was kann man dagegen tun. Und dann gab es jetzt hier, das war ja so Ende Februar 2010, gab es dann so eine dedizierte Aktion, diesmal für das ganze Netz abzuschalten. Operation B49, das war so eine Kampagne initiiert von Microsoft, weil die haben auch so ein Team innerhalb von Microsoft, die in diesem Bereich arbeiten und Botnetze studieren, schauen, was kann man dagegen tun. Dann haben aber noch viele andere Leute geholfen, beispielsweise Shadow Server, Leute von der Uni Mannheim, von der TU Wien, von der Uni Bonn, von Symantec, also waren viele involviert. Und da wurde dann eben innerhalb von einer konzentrierten Aktion Whaledeck abgeschaltet. Da kann man sich vorstellen, dass drei verschiedene Bereiche dort wichtig waren. Zum einen hatten wir ja vorhin schon kurz erzählt, dass Whaledeck eben FastFlux benutzt als Einstiegspunkt ins Netz. Deshalb mussten eben diese 270 Domains abgeschaltet werden.
Die sich eben im Kleinen fanden.
Genau.
Das kann man ja relativ leicht testen. Da muss man ja nur irgendwie in den Server davor schalten und gucken, was abgefragt wird. Oder sieht man das direkt im Code?
Ja, verschiedene Binaries hatten verschiedene Domains drin. Aber wenn man die ganzen Binaries sich anschaut, hat man die relativ einfach gefunden. Das interessante hierbei war, dass es dort wirklich einen Gerichtsurteil dazu gab. Also Microsoft hat wirklich dem Richter klargemacht, dass das ganze Netz Schaden anrichtet. Die haben das quasi so argumentiert, dadurch, dass Whaledeck jede Menge Spam verschickt, ist es eben so, dass sie jede Menge Kosten bei Hotmail haben. Einfach Kosten, die wirklich als Schaden anfallen bei ihnen. Und haben das dann ausgearbeitet für den Richter. Und das war so ein, denke ich mal, sehr wichtiger Aspekt. Das war einfach eins der ersten Gerichtsurteile in diesem ganzen Bereich, was Microsoft dort eben erreicht hat.
Wo haben sie dieses Gerichtsurteil?
In den USA. Weil der Glücksfall hier in diesem Fall war, dass alle Domains in.com waren. Also alle bei VeriSign. Macht es eben ein bisschen einfacher juristisch gesehen. Es gibt eine Webseite, wo auch die ganzen Gerichtsurkumente verfügbar sind. Es ist eigentlich ganz interessant, sich das mal durchzulesen. Es sind hunderte Seiten. Ja, Link kenne ich nicht auswendig, aber gibt es dann später auf der Seite zum Chaos Radio. Gut, wie gesagt, so dieser eine Punkt, die ganzen Domains wurden abgeschaltet per Gerichtsurteil. Also Microsoft hat dann quasi das Urteil gehabt, konnte damit zu VeriSign gehen und dort wurden diese Domains abgeschaltet. Sprich, diese Einstiegspunkte oder Einstiegsdomains sind zwar nach einmal weg.
Und die hatten auch kein Fallback in ihrem Botnetz? Wenn die alle nicht zu erreichen sind, dann...
Nein, weil die Domains sind ja quasi schon der Fallback. Dann haben die Leute von Shadow Server dafür gesorgt, dass... von Wale gibt's ihm auch so. Es gibt auch einige statische Server, dass die alle abgeschaltet wurden. Das waren dann jeweils viele Telefonate, die dort geführt wurden mussten, dass sie einfach bei den Hostern angerufen haben und denen dann gesagt haben, hier diese Maschine ist definitiv böse, hier ist der Beweis dazu und sorgt dafür, dass sie abgeschaltet wird. War ziemlich schwierig, weil die standen eben auch in verschiedenen Ländern, in verschiedenen Zeitzonen, aber sie haben es dann trotzdem geschafft, einfach auf Druck gemacht, um zu schauen, dass diese Maschinen offline gehen. Sonderweise standen auch drei in Deutschland. Können wir vielleicht später noch drauf eingehen. Weil das ist eben, wie gesagt, ein internationales Problem eigentlich. Dadurch wurden eben diese Backendserver abgeschaltet, die eben auch so Teil oder wichtig waren fürs Netz, weil einfach darüber die Eingreifer Befehle eigentlich so abgeben konnten. Genau, und dann haben wir also jemand von der Uni Mannheim, der Ben Stock, und der hat dort die meisten Implementierungen oder die Implementierung gemacht. Das war dann eben der Angriff, oder der Angriff klingt so hart, aber prinzipiell so gegen diese Peer-to-Peer-Komponente vorgehen, in die wir dann eben Störtraffic reingeschickt haben.
Neu sprechen können wir das Verteidigungsmaßnahme nennen.
Stimmt. Diese Verteidigungsmaßnahme bestand dann eben darin, dass wir falsche Peer-List-Updates geschickt haben und dann quasi die Bots auf einmal dachten, es gibt jetzt quasi nur noch, oder die coolen Peers, sind quasi die IP-Adressen unter unserer Kontrolle, also unter dem Verteidiger-Kontrolle. Das waren einige IPs von uns. Genau, und dann war es eben so, dass alle Bots einfach auf einmal uns kontaktieren und dadurch, dass wir eben keine Befehle rausgeben, sondern eben denen jeweils sagen, hier, neue Peer-List, sind wir immer noch wir. Sodass die Bots dann einfach immer zu uns kamen und die Bots kannten dann auch quasi niemand anderen mehr im ganzen Netz, die kennen eigentlich nur noch uns. Und so war es dann so, dass die Kommando-Infrastruktur quasi abgeschaltet werden konnte. Weil es gab keine Domains mehr, es gab keine Backend-Server mehr und die P2P-Kommunikation ist auch kaputt. Und jetzt kann der Angreifer einfach keine Befehle mehr zu den Bots schicken.
Und dann lagen sie trocken?
Lagen trocken, ja.
Aber sie sind ja immer noch da.
Genau, das ist eben so das Problem.
Da muss man ja diese Trocken-Infrastruktur, die muss man sozusagen die ganze Zeit aufrechterhalten. Wenn man nicht die ganze Zeit das Wasser hinter den Deichen vorpumpt, dann ist irgendwann Schluss sozusagen.
Genau, das sind eigentlich genau die zwei Probleme, die es eben gibt. Also einen müssen wir eben diese Infrastruktur haben, dass es auch generell so auch bei einigen anderen Botnetzen wird eben so ein Synch-Holing gemacht, dass man eben dafür sorgt, dass die Teile der Kommando-Infrastruktur einfach auf Maschinen umgeleitet werden, die unter den Verteidigern, unter der Kontrolle der Verteidiger stehen. Dass die Domains beispielsweise so umgebogen werden, dass die auf IPs zeigen, die unter der Kontrolle der Guten stehen. Nur, die müssen wirklich diese Maschinen auch online halten, was natürlich definitiv ein Ressourcenproblem ist. Oder jetzt auch bei Welldeck, da braucht man auch so einen kleinen Loadbalancer davor, damit einfach wenig auf einmal geditost werden, weil wir so viele Anfragen bekommen. Da muss man eben wirklich auch schon ein paar Maschinen wirklich hinstellen, die die Load handeln können.
Und so einen irgendwie Selbstzerstörungsmechanismus haben die aber nicht eingebaut. So nach dem Motto, so ein speziell verschlussetes Kommando und dann löscht sich der Bot-Kline komplett raus, damit er nicht auffindbar ist oder so?
Doch, prinzipiell gibt es sowas typischerweise auch. Früher so ein Dot-Delete, der hat dafür gesorgt, dass der Bot sich entfernt. Nur das ist dann eben das juristische Minenfeld, in dem man sich bewegt. Weil so Befehle auf Maschinen ausführen, die nicht unter meiner Kontrolle sind, sagen die Juristen, darfst du nicht. Oder auch ethisch natürlich auch ein Problem, ein legales Problem.
Weiß ja gar ja, was da noch mit alles mit sich zieht. Andererseits ist das eh schon alles Zombies. Ich meine, wenn man den dann irgendwie noch den finalen Rettungsschuss gibt, die waren ja schon fast tot.
Ja, aber das ist so das Beispiel, was dann eben als Gegenargument für so was jeweils gebracht wird, ist, was ist, wenn das jetzt eine Maschine ist, die an einer Herz-Lungen-Maschine hängt und jetzt durch deinen Befehl stürzt die Maschine ab. Das ist nicht ein bisschen konstruiert das Beispiel, aber kann man sich...
Ja, ich möchte nicht an einer Herz-Lungen-Maschine, die von Windows 95 betrieben wird, hacken, ehrlich gesagt.
Gut, ich auch nicht. Aber trotzdem, so die Seiteneffekte, das ist eben...
Ja, ich verstehe schon, das ist natürlich in der Tat eine Fragestellung. Andererseits muss man sich halt auch überlegen, wie wird man das Zeug jetzt wieder los, weil man ja nicht für jedes Botnetz, was da aufkommt, und ich meine, da weiß ja gar nicht, wie viele Wale-Dags es jetzt schon wieder gibt, weil die Leute sind ja so nicht gefunden worden. Also es ist ja nur das Netz ausgeschaltet worden.
Genau, also wie gesagt, der eine direkt wieder zwei neue Probleme. Also ein Problem, wie gesagt, wir müssen die Infrastruktur im Laufen halten. Und ein anderes Problem ist, dass die Maschinen immer noch infiziert sind. Und wie sage ich diesen ganzen Maschinen Bescheid? Nicht den Maschinen, sondern den Benutzern Bescheid. Weil ich so, Confica hat mir ja schon mal angesprochen, gibt es so sechs, sieben Millionen infizierte Maschinen. Nur wie sage ich dem Nutzer das? Das ist eben problematisch. Was es dort beispielsweise gibt, dass man sammelt die IP-Adressen.
Wie meinst du, ist das problematisch, weil die dann irgendwie einen Schock kriegen oder weil es keine Möglichkeit gibt, da zu notifizieren, wenn man nicht weiß, wo die sind? Genau, es gibt keine Möglichkeit. Aufklärungsproblematik ist ein weiterer Teil.
Was man dort eben dann macht, ist, man sammelt die IP-Adressen, von denen man weiß, die sind infiziert, gibt diese Liste von IPs jeweils dem Provider und dann hofft man, dass der Provider seinen Kunden Bescheid sagt. Nur, da gibt es ja keinen Druck, also wenn der Provider Lust hat, macht er es, aber wenn er sagt, okay, danke für die Liste und Teff Null, dann geht es ja leider nicht weiter.
Und sind die Provider so drauf, man möchte ja fast meinen, dass sie verpflichtet sein müssten, zumindest so ethisch-moralisch, aber sie kriegen kein Geld dafür, ne?
Genau, ein ISP ist ja nur der Leitungsprovider, sagen sie jeweils.
Aber sind auch die Herrscher über die IP-Adresse und den Polizisten, geben sie die ja auch, wenn die die haben wollen?
Ja, also ich finde es cool, wenn die sowas machen würden, aber geht ja, also, schwierig.
Na ja, da muss man wahrscheinlich so ein Memorandum of understanding, so ein weltweites Mal machen, hier mit rote Schleife und we care about our customers und wenn man da irgendwie nicht teil ist und diesen Batch-over, die er auf seiner Webseite hat, dann ist man irgendwie doof, so was könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Das wird jetzt, glaube ich, spannend in den nächsten Monaten, weil da gibt es ja jetzt in Deutschland genauso eine Initiative, wie die das machen will. Die ist gesteuert oder wird koordiniert vom EKO, also dem Bundesverband der ASPs quasi, wird unterstützt von der Regierung, ich glaube Budget sind so um die 2 Millionen Euro, die die haben, wo einfach sich die großen ASPs, ich glaube 8 Stück in der Zahl oder so, einfach was die machen wollen, ist, die wollen so eine Infrastruktur aufbauen, dass man den Kunden jeweils Bescheid sagen kann, deine Maschine ist infiziert, tu was dagegen. Und zum anderen soll ja auch so eine Notfall-Hotline eingerichtet werden, dass die Kunden, wenn sie wissen, okay meine Maschine ist infiziert, können die dort anrufen und bekommen dann kompetente Hilfe. So ist das angedacht. Ich bin mal gespannt, was daraus wird. Ich denke, die Initiative ist gut und wenn wirklich die was machen, glaube ich, kann man da auch was erreichen.
Oder hast du ja vorhin gesagt, dass es mit ein paar Maschinen in Deutschland schwierig wäre, beim Runterfahren dieses Netz?
Das, was eher interessant war, ist, dass diese Maschinen wirklich in Deutschland stehen. Dass wir eben auch hier diese Provider haben oder diese Hoster eigentlich, denen war es nicht ganz egal, dass quasi dort eine Maschine steht, aber die wussten es eher nicht. In diesem Fall war es so ein Provider.
Also es waren jetzt keine infizierten Maschinen, sondern so Teil der Infrastruktur, so Backends sozusagen. Also es war so Virtual Hosts, die explizit davon aufgesetzt wurden, von den Betreibern der Botnetze, um das Botnetz aufrechtzuerhalten, so was meinst du. Okay, verstehe.
War konkret so ein Host da in der Nähe von Frankfurt. Einfach, ja.
Naja, ich meine, warum auch nicht? Ich meine, warum? Deutschland ist ja jetzt nicht immun gegen sowas und man kann sich ja jeder irgendwie seinen Host aufmachen und die wissen ja nicht, was da drauf läuft.
Die hätten eben lange den Ruf gehabt, dass sie nicht wirklich kooperativ sind. Da muss ich einfach, glaube ich, das wirklich unterstützen oder sowas. Ich weiß nicht, was daran dran ist. Mittlerweile haben die auch viel gelernt, muss ich sagen. Ich glaube, war eben vor allem das Problem, dass sie einfach sehr billiger Hoster sind, weshalb einfach zu wenig Personal hatten, die wirklich sowas nicht damit auskennen. Die haben, glaube ich, in der Zeit viel gelernt, denke ich mal.
Die richtigen Billigen sind nicht nur billig, sondern auch noch nicht in der Lage, das Personal aufzubringen, um dann was dagegen zu tun.
Genau, und dann der dritte Aspekt, den wir eben kurz angesprochen haben, ist eben, klar, wir haben jetzt zwar technisch viel gemacht, die Kommunikationsinfrastruktur quasi gestört, aber die Angriffe an sich laufen natürlich noch rum. Wir haben denen jetzt quasi das Spielzeug weggenommen, aber die denken jetzt nicht, okay, ich mach jetzt morgen einen richtigen Job, deshalb.
Na, die haben ja gemerkt, wie weit sie kommen, und ohne dass sie da groß erkannt werden, können sie ja sogar mit derselben Software wieder starten.
Genau, oder, ja, ich denke, das ist ein bisschen besser, dass sie eben dafür sorgen, dass man die Peer-Listen nicht so überschreiben kann und sonstige Dinge. Und dann sehen wir bestimmt was Neues bald.
Ja, ich meine, wenn ich mich jetzt noch mal so ein bisschen in die Situation von Angreifern versetze, so was würde ich tun? Ich meine, man könnte ja auch, also was ja geil, ob sowas schon drin ist, aber so eine Todmann-Taste, ja, also wenn ich nicht innerhalb von dem und dem Zeitraum dieses spezielle Kommando bekommen habe, ja, ich weiß nicht, wie leicht sich so etwas im Code durch die Analyse finden lässt, ja, wahrscheinlich nicht so einfach, wenn auch nicht unmöglich, dann was weiß ich, dann gucke ich mal ganz woanders nach, wo ich bisher noch nie nachgeguckt habe und versuche irgendwie mich darüber wieder neu zu booten. Sowas schon mal aufgekommen?
Also die haben teilweise schon so Backup-Mechanismen, dass sie eben verschiedene Methoden haben für Kommandos zu bekommen und ich glaube, da kann man, ich glaube, wenn man da kreativ ist, also wenn die Angreifer da sehr kreativ sind, kann man da auch vielfältiger Art und Weise einfach eine Kommando-Infrastruktur aufbauen, die einfach auch robust ist und die man einfach nicht, oder einfach fünf verschiedene Wege, wenn er es nicht tut, mache ich dann Fallback auf den zweiten und so weiter und das ist dann ich, dann wird es schwierig. Oder dass man ja die Krypto, wie gesagt, richtig macht, dass man eben alles mögliche signiert, verschlüsselt und alles richtig macht. Oder dass man, was ich, sowas wie Anonymisierungsdienste nutzen würde, wobei Thor wahrscheinlich von der Performance her nicht ganz gut ist, also Bandbreite ist ein bisschen klein, aber dass man eben, oder was ich, Deganografie benutzt, um einfach auch zu verschleiern, was da genau passiert. Ich denke, aus Angreifersicht könnte man dann schon viele gute Sachen machen.
Das heißt, man bleibt auf jeden Fall hier auch beschäftigt in dem Business.
Ja, das ist eben so ein bisschen, zum einen eben interessant, weil einfach, gibt immer neue Challenges quasi, aber natürlich auch so ein bisschen frustrierend, weil, wie gesagt, die Angreifer laufen immer noch rum und die werden sich einfach ein bisschen was Neues ausdenken und kommen in ein paar Monaten wieder. Klar, ist natürlich schön für uns, wir haben immer was zu tun, aber so auf Dauer, ich weiß nicht, ob das hier so gut ist.
Was vorhin, jetzt will ich mal auch nicht zu sehr hin- und herspringen. Dann bleiben wir vielleicht noch mal kurz bei den Botnetzen als solchen. Ich habe ja jetzt auch verschiedene Sachen schon erwähnt, also Storm und Valdak, die halt offensichtlich viel miteinander zu tun haben. Sehr wahrscheinlich, dass da dieselben Leute dahinter stehen und auch sehr wahrscheinlich, dass sie demnächst wieder zuschlagen, wenn sie es nicht schon längst getan haben, wo ihre anderen Infrastrukturen sozusagen ausgetrocknet sind. Letzten Endes kann man dem Ganzen eigentlich wirklich auch nur dann herwerden, wenn man eben auch Mittel und Wege findet, die zu finden. Das ist natürlich sehr schwierig, weil das in gewisser Hinsicht ja auch eine, in Anführungsstrichen, so eine Überwachung des Internets irgendwie nahelegt, nicht wahr? Um dann sozusagen nämlich genau das, wo wir ja sozusagen auf der politischen Diskussion auch mal in diesem Fahrwasser befinden, so nein, wir wollen keine Automatismen im Netzwerk haben, mit denen Dinge automatisch runtergefahren werden können und so weiter, eben aus den bekannten Problemen. Ich sag mal wieder, dieses Sicherheit versus Freiheit, das ist natürlich da auch in der digitalen Welt ein echt, echt schwieriges Feld. Aber was würdest du denn so vorschlagen, was wäre denn schön, wenn es das gäbe, was vielleicht jetzt nicht leicht politisch vollkommen fragwürdig ist, um solche Mechanismen besser verteidigungsfähig zu machen, abgesehen davon, dass die Maschinen sicherer werden sollten?
Ja, das ist schwierig. Also ich toffe mal, dass diese Initiative vom ECO, dass das Erfolg hat, dass die ISPs anfangen, was zu tun, dass die wirklich den Kunden Bescheid sagen. Also es gibt einige ISPs, die auch schon aktiv Sachen machen, die ihre Kunden schützen. Was wäre es in dem Domains, wo man weiß, die sind jetzt böse, weil die zu einem Botnetz gehören, dass die einfach nicht aufgelöst werden oder anders aufgelöst werden oder der Traffic weitergeleitet wird. Da gibt es eben ISPs, die sowas machen, die so helfen. Aber natürlich ist schnell der Gedanke, was ist Zensur, wie wird da gefiltert und solche Dinge. Ich komme ja aus NRW, ich kenne ja dort die Problematik mit unserer Regierung, die uns dort rotten.com und andere Seiten vorhält. Das ist eben schwierig.
Vor Enthält. rotten.com möchte ich mir nicht vorhalten. Die kann man ja echt sperren, da habe ich keinen Mitleid. Ihr klickt da jetzt nicht drauf.
Don't. Oh nein, falsches Wort.
Die kommt auch nicht in die Linkliste.
Aber das ist natürlich ein sehr kurzer Weg zwischen dieser Art von sperren oder was darf man sperren, wo hört man auf, ist natürlich politisch sehr, sehr schwierig. Oder gerade auch ein anderes Thema, was eben so ein rotes Tuch ist, ist eben diese Deep Packet Inspection. Also darf der ISP reinschauen. Politisch ist das definitiv nicht gewollt.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass das groß helfen würde, oder?
Ja, man könnte natürlich entsprechende Schutzmechanismen aufbauen, um zu schauen, ist das Paket, finde ich da Spuren von Bot-Traffic und das Sperren oder so aufhalten oder so.
Kann Spuren von Botnetzen enthalten.
Aber es ist natürlich ein Problem mit der Force Positives oder wenn es eben Verschlüsselungen genutzt wird, kann man ja nichts sehen und so was. Und wenn man so ein Infrastruktur aufbaut, zeigt die Erfahrung ja, dass die dann irgendwann für andere Sachen missbraucht wird oder gebraucht wird.
Oder fast nur noch.
Oder fast nur noch, ja. Deshalb, politisch ist das definitiv auch schwierig. Aber wie gesagt, ich hoffe mal, dass jetzt so die freiwillige Zusammenarbeit der ESPs, dass das schon mal was hilft, dass die wirklich dann anfangen, ihren Kunden Bescheid zu sagen und so.
Wie fit sind denn diese Leute, die das machen? Also mit welcher Augenhöhe befindet man sich da?
Ich denke, da gibt es ein relativ großes Spektrum. Zum einen einfach nur die Kiddies, die einfach nur Code nehmen, kompilieren und loslegen und vielleicht kleine Änderungen machen. Also das eine Ende vom Spektrum, das geht dann immer weiter, dass das professioneller wird, dass die Leute wirklich Geld machen, eigenen Code entwickeln, neue Techniken entwickeln. Bis eben hin zu der Spitze, wo dann sowas wie die Operation Aurora ist, was im Bereich so Industrie-Spülnage oder Ghost-Net, wo es dann auf Regierungsebene ist, das sind dann keine Kiddies mehr, sondern das ist dann professionell.
Aber auch professionell im Sinne von, dass das wirklich gute Coder sind, dass das wirklich Leute sind, die den Eindruck haben, dass das mit Leuten zu tun haben, die einfach wissen, was sie tun.
Also jetzt hier Storm und Wale Deck war definitiv auch eine interessante Konzepte, die sich entwickelt haben oder ausgesagt haben, gut umgesetzt eigentlich und klar, das ist ein...
Keiler Anfänger.
Die macht das nicht seit gestern wahrscheinlich, ja.
Na gut, ich meine auch, dieser ganze Spam-Versand und so hat man ja immer schon gesehen, da sind dann einfach mal Leute, die sich eben überlegen, verdiene ich jetzt irgendwie 2000 Euro im Monat, indem ich mich bei irgendeiner mittelständischen Bude einsperren lasse? Oder verdiene ich irgendwie 20.000 bis 200.000 im Monat, indem ich halt irgendwie Leuten Mails schicke und selber Schuld, wenn sie draufklicken? Das sind ja auch so ein bisschen die Denken, die sich da glaube ich schnell entfaltet, dass man das dann auch so vollkommen ausblendet. Typisches kriminalitäts-, kriminellen Realitätssicht so, naja, wenn ich es nicht mache, machen es andere und was man halt nicht immer alles so hört, ne? Also ist es dann wahrscheinlich auch. Irgendjemand wird sich dieser Problematik immer noch annehmen. Vielleicht kannst du noch, also ich weiß, es ist jetzt nicht so dein Kernforschungsthema gewesen, aber was weißt du und was kannst du sagen über Konfigur, weil der hat ja nun auch Welle geschlagen.
Konfigur war eben interessant, weil es einfach krass ist.
Ist das jetzt auch so ein klassisches Botnetz in dem Sinne?
Ja schon, also es hat zwar viel Wurmcharakter, aber es gibt eben auch diesen Kommunikationsaspekt, also Kontrollmechanismusaspekt, dass der Angreifer auch Befehle hinschicken kann. Es gibt eine Website, wo das auch detailliert aufgeschlüsselt wird, eben nach ASNs. Und da sieht man eben, das China-Net ist immer noch Nummer eins, mit etwas mehr als eine Million investierter Maschinen.
Was für eine Website ist das?
konfigureworkinggroup.com Ah so explizit dafür. Genau, weil das ist mittlerweile so eine Zusammenarbeit von vielen Leuten aus der Industrie, sind sie auch aus dem akademischen Bereich, also gerade die Uni Born ist da sehr aktiv, wo jetzt schon monatelang das Ganze getrackt wird oder auch Shadow Server klappt. Und dort einfach studiert wird, was macht das Botnetz und so. Wenn man da auf der Seite runter scrollt, gibt es da unten so eine Auswertung oder irgendwo muss man vielleicht auch nicht draufklicken. So eine Art, ich glaube die werden jeden Tag oder jede Woche aktualisiert, die Statistiken. Das ist eben erschreckend, wie viele Maschinen dort laufen. Oder infiziert sind. Ich denke, das war ja vor allem interessant.
Also es bezieht sich eigentlich nur auf Windows, oder?
Klar, das war eine Windows-Schrachtstelle, die damals neu rauskam. Das war dann wieder mal nach langer Zeit wieder etwas, was man wirklich remote ohne Autorisierung quasi ausnutzen konnte. Klassischer, oder was jetzt klassicher war, war auf jeden Fall ein Overflow, der benutzt wurde. Für Code auszuführen, das war eben so, der Konfigurator war der Board, der das benutzt hat.
Das heißt, da musste man gar nicht erst auf Mails draufklicken oder so, sondern man musste eigentlich nur seinen Rechner am Netz haben und dann konnte man sich das Ding schon einfangen.
Genau, das war so ein Verbreitungsweg. Der zweite Verbreitungsweg, der aber auch sehr gut funktioniert hat, war eben quasi die moderne Floppy, also der USB-Stick. Sprich, wenn man USB-Stick reinsteckt, infiziert er den USB-Stick. Ist eigentlich relativ gut aus Social-Engineering-Mäßigkeit gemacht. Und zwar, wenn der Dialog dann hochkommt mit wollen sie den Datenträger öffnen oder so, tauschen das Icon auch aus. Das sieht dann eben so aus, als ob man das nur öffnen will, aber eigentlich führt er die Datei auch schon aus. Und wenn man es dann in den nächsten Computer wieder reinsteckt, also wird der dann auch infiziert. Wie gesagt, Floppys von 2010 sind die USB-Sticks. Und was er auch noch macht, ist Passwörterraten und so was. Er hat eben so verschiedene Weiterverbreitungsmechanismen und dadurch ist er eben ziemlich robust.
Und die Schwachstelle, die ihr da ausgenutzt habt, was war das?
Das war die Schwachstelle, ja gute Frage, MS-09-076 würde ich sagen oder MS-08-077. Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, was das war, weil sie jetzt im Moment nicht mehr...
Du musstest jetzt mir nicht aufs letzte Bett runterbrannen, aber was für eine Art...
War irgendwie ein Overflow, wenn ich das richtig genau habe. Und wie gesagt, wieder Remote Code Execution eigentlich, also ein Dienst, der per PC und so weiter.
Okay, gut, also das, was man eigentlich glaubte, schon los geworden zu sein oder weitgehend auch schon los geworden ist, hat an der Stelle einfach nochmal funktioniert.
Ja, war aber auch eher nach Jahren eigentlich wieder nochmal so ein Exploit, war ihm jahrelang echt ruhig an dieser Front, aber dann gab es eben nochmal was und wurde dann direkt von Bots ausgenutzt.
Und ist dieses Netz halt noch aktiv?
Ja, wie gesagt, es gibt eben noch Millionen Rechner. Interessanterweise haben die Angreifer das nie wirklich benutzt, also nie irgendwie benutzt, um Swam zu verschicken oder Informationen zu stehlen. Also das ist eben das, was eben noch so ein bisschen mysteriös ist über Configure, glaube ich.
Achso, das ist mehr so HIV-Virus und weniger AIDS?
Genau.
Und gibt es denn Erkenntnisse darüber, was er theoretisch tun könnte? Also was in diesem Code sozusagen an Aktivitäten verborgen ist?
Nee, also der hat eher so den Mechanismus, dass er einfach von Remote Code runterladen kann und ihn ausführen kann. Sprich, der Angreifer könnte dort liebige Sachen quasi machen.
So richtig so Windows-Code kriegen und dann irgendwas machen, okay. Also war ja im Prinzip schon wieder bei dem, was ich meinte, so mit VM. Wahrscheinlich die VM ist dann irgendwie Windows.
Genau, aber wie gesagt, instanterweise wird das nie richtig von uns das Netz. Das ist eben auch so ein bisschen mysteriös, glaube ich.
Haben die Angst vor dem eigenen Erfolg oder wollten sie sich nur alle Optionen offenhalten und meinten es eigentlich gar nicht so?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Oder vielleicht wollen sie es einfach nur gewinnbietend verkaufen. So nach dem Motto, wir tun gar nichts Schlimmes, aber falls mal jemand eine tolle Idee hat, was man mal Schlimmes tun könnte, da hätten wir dann irgendwie die richtige Startplattform dafür. Genau.
7 Millionen Rechner, die auf einmal die Roots, Nameserver, DDoS und auch so.
Es ist ein bisschen knifflig, sich so in die Köpfe reinzudenken. Sind denn überhaupt schon mal irgendwelche Botnetzbetreiber gefunden worden?
Ja schon, typischerweise dann eben nicht so die High-Profile-Leute, also die guten, sondern eher dann doch die 17 oder vielleicht 20, 25-Jährigen.
Der Motivation im Wesentlichen noch aus Jugendbestand.
Genau, ja. Oder teilweise haben die auch schon finanzielle Schaden gemacht, eben über Click-Fraud oder Spam und sowas. Klar, aber ich denke, man bekommt die wenigstens leider, ja schon leider, aber dann typischerweise männlich, irgendwas zwischen 17 und 25 Jahre alt und die haben dann irgendwelche Fehler gemacht und dadurch kann man die dann zurückverfolgen und dann wirklich auch finden. Oder eben so der klassische Trick, einfach follow the money, einfach schauen, wenn die irgendwie Geld aus dem Ding machen, wie kann ich dem Geldfluss folgen und so, dass man die Leute dann darüber bekommt.
Ich möchte gar nicht wissen, wie viele Leute jetzt hier auf dumme Ideen kommen, wenn sie diese Sendung hören. Aber das ist natürlich ein echtes Problem. Das hatten wir am Anfang jetzt schon mal, aber mich interessiert das auch nochmal. Es gibt auch Botnetze, die auf Mac unterwegs sind, bloß sie sind noch nicht als besonders gefährlich kategorisiert.
Das gibt es auch nicht so weit verbreitet. Was die dann häufig machen, ist, dass sie, es gibt ja diese Webseiten, wo man, also ich mache so ein Peer-to-File-Sharing nicht so viel, aber mittlerweile ist der Trend eher, dass man so Rapid-Share oder sowas geht, glaube ich. Rapid-Share einfach suchen kann oder einfach man weiß, wo man sucht und findet dann eben den entsprechenden Crack oder Varus dort auf dieser Seite und die geben sich dann eben aus, als wäre ich das neue iLife und in Wirklichkeit ist das iLife plus Trojaner und die Leute infizieren sich quasi selber. Und das ist, wie gesagt, auf Mac noch nicht so weit verbreitet, einfach, das ist eher so. Es gibt diese Art von Angriffen, die ja auch langsam professioneller werden, aber noch nicht viele.
Aber ich meine, die Plattform wird immer populärer derzeit, das heißt, es ist durchaus davon auszugehen, dass diese Angriffe auch weiter zunehmen und wenn man sich es halt selber runterlädt, dann gibt es eigentlich auch wenig wirksamen Schutz dagegen, insbesondere wenn man der Meinung ist, man hätte eben jetzt das neue iLife und man will es natürlich auf jeden Fall starten und dann ist es meistens schon so spät. Aber können denn die Betriebssysteme auf der Ebene, nachdem was runtergeladen wurden, eigentlich in irgendeiner Form so eine Infektion feststellen? Also es gibt ja auch so verschiedene Konzepte und Ideen, wie man Betriebssysteme bauen könnte, damit sie sozusagen in sich inherent etwas sicherer sind.
Es gibt ja einige interessante Konzepte eigentlich, was hier so als Konzept eigentlich relativ interessant klingt eigentlich, ist, dass man jeweils für bestimmte Aufgaben, für bestimmte VMs hat. Ich habe eine in meinem Banking-VM, wo ich einfach mein Online-Banken drin mache und dann eine VM, in der ich sowas nur wie Mails mache und eine VM, in der ich sowas mache wie Internet-Rumsurfen und wenn ich dann in der VM, wo ich surfe, einfach irgendwas irgendwie kompromottiert werde, kann ich immer noch sicher sein, dass, oder ziemlich sicher sein auf jeden Fall, dass meine Banking-VM immer noch okay ist. Usability ist dort meistens das Problem. Also wie kann man jetzt, Beispiel, was ich auch aus meiner VM, wo ich Mail drin mache, vielleicht auf einen Link draufklicken können und muss eigentlich in die andere VM rein oder sowas oder wenn ich Sachen synchronisieren will zwischen den verschiedenen VMs und sowas, das ist Usability dort meistens noch das Problem. Aber die einzelnen Sachen, die man abschottet, ist ja auch so ein alter Gedanke, das sich vielleicht langsam mehr und mehr durchsetzt.
Ja, wobei das natürlich dann echte Probleme bei der Interprozess-Datenaustausch geschieht. Du hast ja auch schon gesagt, du schaust ja jetzt Smartphone-Plattformen an, da kommen wir jetzt an der Idee vom iPhone auch nicht so recht dran vorbei, das iPhone hat ja dahingehend ein paar Sachen adressiert, die wir jetzt besprochen haben, als das zum Beispiel der Installationsvorgang, wenn man sich das Ding nicht jetzt selber aufgemacht hat mit so einem J-Break, wie man das so schön nennt, man ja die Software nur autorisiert vom Hersteller bekommt über diesen Application Store, die Programme in sich noch mal signiert sind und wenn sie dann eben laufen, auch in ihrer eigenen Sandbox laufen. Hältst du das für ein ausreichend robustes System, um sozusagen Angriffe von außen zu verhindern oder ist das auch nur die halbe Geschichte?
Die Idee ist gut, doch die hält man auch nicht bereit. Klar, Konzept super, allerdings die Implementierung hat natürlich wieder so ein paar Macken. Ein oder zwei Monate her haben die Jungs von Zynamics, so eine Firma aus Bochum, die haben wirklich demonstriert, wie ein Angriff auf dem iPhone laufen könnte. Man hat sein Mobile Safari, geht auf eine Webseite, die Webseite nutzt eine Schwachstelle, greift den Browser an, nutzt eine Schwachstelle im Webkit aus, führt Code aus über dieses Return-Oriented Programming, was wir auch schon mal vorher erklärt haben, und sorgt dann dafür, dass die SMS-Datenbank an einen Server geschickt wird, der unter der Kontrolle des Angreifers steht. Also ich gehe einfach nur auf eine Webseite und der Angreifer kann dann meine SMS-Datenbank stehlen. Das ist natürlich dann, wie gesagt, Konzept super, aber Probleme gibt es dann immer noch in dem Konzept.
Okay, das Konzept schließt nicht alles aus. Aber du meinst, grundsätzlich ist diese Kombination dieses Modells, Sandbox, Signieren plus authentifizierter Server und die Installation kann eben nur sozusagen über diesen einen autorisierten Weg gehen, wäre schon ein Modell, mit dem man Computer generell sicherer machen könnte. Ich versuch das jetzt, diese Idee jetzt auch gerade mal wieder so auf die Desktop-Systeme zurückzubekommen.
Also macht schon einen Sinn, nur hat man dann natürlich auch das Problem, sehen wir ja auch bei dem iPhone schön, wer sorgt dafür, dass Sachen in den App-Store reinkommen.
Ja klar.
Dort hat sich das Problem, dass Apple nicht alles zulässt und so.
Ja klar, ich wollte jetzt nicht diese politische Diskussion mit der inhaltlichen Kontrolle aufmachen, das ist natürlich nochmal so ein Problem für sich, sondern jetzt so rein technisch, ich könnte mir ja sozusagen auch meinen App-Store wählen.
Oder den Marketplace.
Bei Android ist es ja so, dass man quasi die Auswahl hat zwischen verschiedenen und im Prinzip ist das ja, das Konzept ist ja da auch dasselbe. Genau. Ich weiß nicht, wie viel das schon, wie da die Sicherheitsbranche sich da schon drauf gestürzt hat bei Android.
Also gibt es eben schon so ein paar Leute, die in dem Bereich was machen, das ist ihm interessant, weil einfach, da können die Leute ja selber sich knien, aber anscheinend hat Google das gute Kontrolle, also gibt es zwar ab und zu auch böse Apps, die reinkommen, aber die werden dann auch schnell entfernt.
Also es gibt definitiv auch andere Wege, wie man das Ganze machen könnte, insbesondere denke ich jetzt gerade mal so auf Firmen, ich meine bei Firmen, Behörden, wir hatten das schon, da ist ja eigentlich genau so dieses Vertrauensding, da hat man ja eigentlich auch die Infrastruktur, die man haben will, da hat man irgendwie eine IT, die ja sowieso meistens schon so ein bisschen die Hand drauf hat, was installiert werden darf oder nicht, was dann auch dazu führt, dass bestimmte Dinge auch nicht aktualisiert wird, aber das ist immer ein anderes Problem, aber wenn man das jetzt mal so weiterdenkt, könnte man ja auch sagen, okay, unsere Arbeitsplatzcomputer hier, die sind nur dafür gedacht, die und die Software zu fahren und sonst irgendwie gar nichts, ja, da hat nichts runtergeladen zu werden. Warum nicht, wenn das Betriebssystem das vorsieht, diese generelle Funktionalität von ich installiere mir was einfach auszuschalten, geht einfach gar nicht mehr. Stattdessen gibt es nur noch signierten Code, nur noch eine Installationsprozedur, die eben einen besonderen Vertrauenslevel, Zugangscode, Key, keine Ahnung erfordert, damit die Software überhaupt draufkommt und das Ganze kommt dann eben aber auch noch von einem Applikationsserver, der bei uns auch noch selber im Haus steht.
Und ich muss natürlich auch Sandboxen das Ganze, weil sonst kann ich ja immer noch Backs in der Software haben.
Genau, da wird es natürlich dann wieder schwierig, weil das generelle Konzepte sozusagen verhindert und auch, sagen wir mal, so Dateisysteme, so wie sie heute sind, sind natürlich auch ein wunderbarer Verbreitungsweg, aber schon, wenn man quasi bei der Installation dann eine Sperre machen würde, es würde schon was bringen. Ohne, dass man jetzt zu sehr eingeschränkt ist, weil am Arbeitsplatz ist es ja eigentlich egal, ich meine gut. Kann man nichts installieren, wenn man was installieren will, muss man seinen eigenen Computer mitbringen oder so.
Also, es wird schon helfen, denke ich schon. Klar, ist natürlich nicht so flexibel. Ich glaube ja nicht, dass du einfach einen Rechner benutzen oder gerne benutzen würdest, wo du nicht mal Sachen ausprobieren kannst.
Aber ich würde auch nicht gerne in solchen Firmen arbeiten, von daher komme ich da gar nicht erst hin.
Ja, aber für deine Oma oder so reicht das wahrscheinlich. Ja, genau.
Und ja, gibt es denn noch andere Sicherheitskonzepte und Modelle und Ansätze, die du so da draußen siehst, die in irgendeiner Form hilfreich sein könnten, ohne ein gleich vollständig jeglicher Freiheit zu berauben?
Ich denke, dass im Moment noch ein Problem ist, dass eben, ja, sagen wir Colonel, also Treiber, Sachen, die jetzt im Colonel-Space laufen, weil sie von Trittanbietern oder so, weil sie aber nicht so gut entwickelt wurden und sobald man dort hinten einen Bug findet, ist ja das ganze Betriebssystem quasi wieder kaputt, weil ich kann dann im Colonel-Bereich meinen eigenen Code ausführen und...
Druckertreiber, sowas, OSB, Giraffe, wobei das ja nicht so populär ist, dass es jetzt wirklich an jedem Rechner dran hängt, ne?
Ja, aber die AV, genau, haben jetzt wieder so teilweise Antiviren-Software, die dann ihre eigenen Colonel-Treiber hat und dann hast du da Bugs drin. Das ist natürlich ein bisschen doof, weil du installierst ja ja so ein Tool, was du schützen soll und das bringt neue Bugs mit rein.
Achso, du meinst, die Antiviren-Software bringt ihre eigenen Treiber mit? Echt, wofür denn das? Achso, um diese ganzen Dinge überhaupt abfangen zu können.
Genau, die müssen auch Kernel-Treiber haben.
Ah, ja natürlich, klar.
Genau, und deshalb hast du jede Menge Code dort im Kernel, der einfach nicht so gut geschützt ist. Da bräuchte man glaube ich noch bessere Konzepte, um zu checken, ist der Code gut, beziehungsweise falls was passiert, wie kann man das irgendwie auch, also Sandboxing ist auch nicht so schwierig, aber wie kann man dann den Schaden minimieren oder sowas. Ich glaube, da braucht man noch so eine bessere Abschottung. Oder eben generell auch im User-Space, dass man dort eben schaut, wenn jetzt ein neuer Prozess gestartet wird, wie kann man den irgendwie aufpassen, dass der einfach nicht zu viel Schaden anrichtet oder sowas. Die Frage, wie man es gut macht, so diese ganzen Sachen, die zur Laufzeit Anomalien erkennen, zwar von Idee her super, aber Problem ist eben false positives, das ist einfach viel zu hoch meistens.
Ja, das merkt man ja schon, wie gut das bei Spam nicht funktioniert.
Genau, oder eben sobald ich ja den User irgendwie mit einbeziehe, dass irgendwas klickt, klickt er irgendwann auf alles drauf. So Usability ist definitiv noch was, oder so Security Awareness ist, wo man auch noch was tun muss, quasi den Leuten beibringen, ihr seid im Internet unterwegs und da müsst ihr auch euren Verstand ein bisschen einschalten. Klickt nicht auf alles drauf, weil ihr würdet im realen Leben auch nicht in jede Straße gehen. Das fehlt, glaube ich, die Intuition noch so ein bisschen, aber ich glaube, das wird immer besser.
Oder alles anfassen und so. Das Layer-8-Problem, wie der Programmierer sagt. Ja, Thorsten, haben wir denn irgendeine bahnbrechende Information bisher unseren Hörern vorenthalten?
Puh, wir haben schon über viel gesprochen.
Ja, das stimmt.
Das stimmt.
So war das ja auch gedacht.
Das einzige Thema, was wir noch anfressen können, ist die Malware-Analyse. Weil wir hatten jetzt so die beiden Schritte, dass wir mit den Honeypots Schar-Software automatisiert sammeln. Wir kriegen also hunderte, tausende neue Binaries pro Tag rein. Und jetzt könnte ich mich zwar hinsetzen und mir die nach und nach anschauen, nur wenn pro Tag 500 neue reinkommen und ich pro Tag zwei analysieren kann.
Dann ist so ein bisschen ein Performance-Problem.
Genau, richtig. Ich kann zwar hunderte Leute einstellen, aber bezahlt mir leider keiner. Und deshalb muss man da ja auch irgendwas tun, für das automatisiert zu machen, um einfach jetzt aus dem gegebenen Exemplar der Schar-Software einfach die Verbindung herzustellen, welches Botnetz gehört dazu. Deshalb hat man da den Zwischenschritt. Da haben wir noch nicht so drüber gesprochen. Da haben wir dann jetzt oder wir und auch viele andere, jede Menge Techniken entwickelt, um einfach so eine Schar-Software analysieren zu können. Dort gibt es dann prinzipiell so zwei Lager. Das eine der Lager sagt, wir machen das Ganze statisch. Wir führen also den Code nicht aus, sondern analysieren den ganz. So klassisches Reverse-Engineering. Und dort gibt es ja jahrelang oder jahrzehntelange Erfahrungen schon im ganzen Bereich, wie man einfach so ein Binary analysiert. Viele statische Methoden, sowohl in der Industrie als auch in der Forschung so entwickelt, wo es viele Ansätze gibt. Das andere Lager ist eher so das dynamische Lager. Die sagen, wir führen einfach aus und beobachten zur Laufzeit, was passiert. Ist eben glaube ich so ein anderer Ansatz. Am besten bringen wir die beiden wahrscheinlich zusammen oder so. Dynamische Analyse hat eben ein paar Vorteile, geht typischerweise viel schneller oder schneller, weil man lässt das Bein einfach ausführen und beobachtet, was es macht. Jetzt gerade, wenn ich mir so einen Bot vorstelle, wenn ich den Bot starte, der will sich ja auf dem System installieren, weil der will mein System infizieren. Also kopiert sich irgendwo hin, sorgt dafür, dass ein Registry Key erstellt wird, damit er beim nächsten Reboot wieder da ist.
Also bei Windows einklinkt und existiert.
Und dann, sobald er das gemacht hat, kontaktiert er einfach den Commando-Server, um zu gucken, welchen Befehl soll ich als nächstes ausführen? Was soll ich tun? Genau, da bin ich. Oder einfach, um dem Eingangsscheid zu sagen, dass ein neuer Bot da ist. Deshalb, wenn ich jetzt den Bot einfach ausführe, sehe ich zur Laufzeit quasi schon, was macht er. Das ist ja eigentlich genau das, was wir haben wollen. Wollen wir wissen, was verändert er am System und wo ist der Commando-Server. Deshalb haben wir vor allem Methoden entwickelt aus dem Bereich der dynamischen Analyse. Sandboxing-Lösungen oder dynamische verhaltensbasierte Analyse. Wir lassen das beinü-ausführen und beobachten dann zur Laufzeit, was passiert.
Also schickt der Datenpaket heraus oder nicht zum Beispiel.
Genau. Oder welche Dateien werden auf dem Datalsystem erstellt. Oder welche neuen Red-Dustry-Keys gibt es. Oder eben auch Feinkranolara, welche DLLs werden geladen oder sonst was.
Wie installiert sich eure Software auf diesem Rechner? Also läuft dann sozusagen das Betriebssystem in so einer VM in dem Moment und ihr seid sozusagen drum herum und schaut, was irgendwie aus diesem Computer herauskommt oder?
Da gibt es eben auch verschiedene Ansätze. So der simpelste aller Ansätze kann man sich technisch so vorstellen, ich habe ein System, ich stelle von dem Snapshot für den Board aus, lasse den zwei Minuten laufen, stelle noch einen Snapshot und vergleiche die beiden. Ist natürlich super simpel.
Also im Sinne von man vergleicht für dich den kompletten Speicher- und Platteninhalt sozusagen.
Genau so was, ja. Ist natürlich nicht ganz so gut. Dynamisch bekommt man eben die ganzen Änderungen gar nicht mit. Deshalb so ein besserer Ansatz ist, dass man quasi, man hat sein Windows-System und hat da dann ein Programm und das Programm beobachtet dann das Verhalten des anderen Programms.
So wie ein Debugger sozusagen einen anderen Code überwacht und quasi jeden Systemzugriff abfangen kann etc.
Genau. CW Sandbox ist eben so das Tool, was damals im Rahmen von der Diplomarbeit entwickelt wurde.
Genau, Karsten Willems hat sich der Programmierer dort verewigt.
mwanalysis.org ist die Webseite dazu. Dort haben wir eben dann ein Webinterface zu dem Tool, das man einfach in binary hochladen kann. Dann wird das analysiert und man kommt nach ein paar Minuten einfach den Analyse-Report, wo quasi drin steht, was haben wir beobachtet. Da ist eben so die Idee, wie gesagt, man benutzt API-Hooking, also jeden API-Call, der irgendwie interessant für mich ist, den hooker ich. Also jedes Mal, wenn er ausgeführt wird, wird ein Stück Code von mir zuerst ausgeführt, wo ich Sachen mitloggen kann oder Sachen verändern kann. Und dann fühle ich die eigentliche Funktion aus und kann das auch noch, der Rückkabewert auch noch mal checken oder sowas. Das ist eben so API-Hooking, was die CW Sandbox implementiert. Du bist aber wirklich in der Maschine drin, innerhalb des Windows-Systems und kannst dann da beobachten, was passiert. Dann gibt es noch einen anderen Ansatz. Das wird beispielsweise durch Anubis implementiert. anubis.isaclab.org entwickelt von der TU Wien, wo ich immer auch im Rahmen einer Postdoc-Zeit gearbeitet habe. Die haben etwa zeitgleich mit uns damals so 2006 mit der Entwicklung angefangen. Also Tools sind jetzt auch über die Jahre gewachsen. Und die machen genau die Technik, die du eben kurz skizziert hast. Also ich habe eine virtuelle Maschine und meine Überwachungsschicht ist quasi unter der virtuellen Maschine. Und ich schaue dann quasi von unten in die Maschine rein. Virtual Machine Interspection heißt das. V-MIDI. Und lasse dann in der virtuellen Maschine das Bein durchlaufen und gucke von unten, beobachte ich quasi was passiert. Hat eben Vorteile, Nachteile, also ja jeweils so. Das Schöne ist eben, dass ich sehr fein granular die V-M instrumentieren kann. Ich kann beispielsweise nach jeder Instruktion quasi anhalten, mir alles anschauen oder ich kann auch einfach andere Jumps nehmen, also irgendwie anders verzweigen in der Ausführung oder auch was dabei zum Beispiel geht. So ein Problem bei der dynamischen Analyse ist ja, ich sehe nur einen Code-Ausführungs-Fahrt. Das ist ausführen und wie verhält sich das Binary und innerhalb des Programms ist quasi ein Fahrt, der ausgeführt wird im Vergleich zur statischen Analyse, wo ich ja quasi alles mehr anschauen kann. Was man jetzt mit Anubis machen kann, ist die Idee, ich führe das Programm aus und jedes Mal wenn es abzweigt, mache ich mir so einen Snapshot. Ich speichere mir also, wie ist der Zustand der CPU, das Speicher und so alles und gehe dann erstmal den einen Fahrt entlang, mache das eben, bis ich irgendwann sage, hier gibt es nichts interessantes oder so und dann springe ich zurück, setze diesen Zustand also zum Trackpack, Tracepack und gehe dann in die andere Richtung und schaue mir den anderen Fahrt an, sodass man eben mehrere Fahrte sich kleistisch anschauen kann. Multi-Path Execution.
Klingt, als würde es recht lange dauern, also so im Alltime geht das nicht.
Dauert lange, braucht viel Speicher, also hat Nachteile, ist Forschung.
Sprich, also wenn man wirklich größere Timing an Honeypots hat und von diesen vielen tausend Malware-Impressions, die man da so bekommt aus dem Netz, auch wirklich sinnvoll was herausziehen möchte, dann brauchst du eigentlich auch noch mal so eine kleine Number-Cruncher-Farm von Analysetools, die diese ganzen eingefangenen Malware-Fragmente dann auch wirklich auf den Grund gehen.
Genau, also wir haben so um die 20 Maschinen plus dicke Datenbank plus Web-Server. Und die 20 Maschinen machen eigentlich nur Malware-Analyse den ganzen Tag.
Reicht das dann?
Damit kann man schon einige tausend abdecken.
Aber ihr kriegt nicht wirklich alles analysiert, was euch vorgeworfen wird?
Ne, dafür bräuchten wir noch ein bisschen mehr Hardware. Also wenn jemand uns Hardware sponsern will, gerne.
Was for the greater good?
It's for the greater good auf jeden Fall. Aber prinzipiell sehen wir im Moment auch dran, das so ein bisschen aufzubohren, um einfach mehr Hardware daraus stehen zu haben und das einfach besser zu skalieren. Das Ziel ist eben so was.
Könnt ihr da nicht gleich in so eine Computing-Cloud irgendwie reingehen? Ich meine, das ist doch nur das, was sich da gerade anbietet, weil man irgendwie nicht genug Rechenkapazität hat, oder wäre das zu teuer?
Ja, das Problem ist teuer bei uns. Wir sind in der Uni leider, leider kein kommerzielles Unternehmen. Das ist eben ein Problem. Und das andere ist eben, wir haben schon darüber diskutiert, aber bis jetzt nie wirklich die Leute kontaktiert. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie Amazon wirklich reagieren würde, wenn ich denen sage, wir füllen Chartsoftwaren bei euch aus. Weil da gibt es hier einen natürlich auch bösen Traffic, der rausgeht und so. Das ist eben so der Nachteil.
Und so habt ihr das sozusagen auch in einem contenten Environment, sozusagen, mit abgeschaltetem Internet oder?
Nee, prinzipiell, wir erlauben den Maschinen schon, sagen wir, kontrollierten Zugriff zum Internet. Weil wir wollen jetzt zum Beispiel sehen, welche Maschinen kontaktieren die, für den Commando-Server zu finden. Oder wenn die sich Updates runterladen wollen, werden wir es auch sehen. Man muss natürlich sowas machen, was sich Port 25 sperren, damit einfach keine Spam-Mails rausgehen. Oder die typischen Windows-Ports sperren, damit einfach diese ganze Scan-Traffic einfach rausgeht.
Wenn man das der Amazon-Cloud dann so überantwortet, ist das natürlich dann schon ein bisschen knifflig. Da müsste man das ganze Internet dann nochmal drum herum auch nochmal isolieren. Dass man quasi jeglichen Internet-Traffic dann vielleicht zu euch umleitet. Das wäre dann vielleicht so eine Lösung. Wenn man dann sozusagen nochmal so eine VM hat und wenn man da aus dieser VM Internet rausmacht, dann wird alles geproxied rausgetunnelt. Oder was weiß ich, wie weitergemacht.
Deshalb haben wir eher unsere eigene Infrastruktur.
Ja, kann ich schon nachvollziehen. Aber ich habe halt auch irgendwie nur so daran gedacht, dass wenn man eben mal so eben in Echtzeit irgendwas auch wirklich, also wenn es auch darum geht, Fast-Response zu haben, das ist ja auch bei Security manchmal ganz wichtig, auch sehr schnell dabei zu sein. Dass man dann eben sich unter Umständen auch mal eben mal schnell so einen Rechnerpark von 2.000, 3.000 Maschinen irgendwie holen muss, um das dann wirklich alles untersuchen zu können. Muss noch ein bisschen dran gearbeitet werden. Aber das ist ja eh schon klar geworden hier bei Botnetzen. Das ist irgendwie alles wirklich ein Progress. Die Bösewichter sind unterwegs. So ein bisschen so Tatort-Charakter. Also fühlt man sich nicht die ganze Zeit wie so der dritte Mann, der irgendwie durch die Unterwelt Wiens marschiert. Zum Beispiel aus der Suche nach demselben.
Klar, es ist natürlich auch so eine Art Wettrennen die ganze Zeit, auch so mit den Bösen so ein bisschen. Eine interessante Frage, die auch häufig kommt, ist eben, ob wir auch so Drohungen bekommen von der anderen Seite oder Nachrichten von der anderen Seite.
Genau, seid ihr schon so wichtig?
Nein, zum Glück nicht. Aber es ist natürlich definitiv auch, worüber wir öfter mal...
Was nicht heißt, dass ihr wirkungslos werdet.
Das ja. Worüber wir auch intern öfter diskutieren, ist eben, wenn man sich das jetzt vorstellt, die Welldecks oder die Storm-Leute machen damit Geld, massiv Geld wahrscheinlich. Und wir drehen denen das Spielzeug ab. Ich glaube, die finden uns nicht so nett. Aber bis jetzt hat sich noch niemand gemeldet von denen.
Zum Glück.
Aber das ist natürlich... Klar, das heiße Feld auf jeden Fall.
Muss man wahrscheinlich eine Gegenrechnung aufstellen und mal sagen, okay, wenn wir jetzt hier aktiv werden, dann nehmen wir der Wirtschaft sozusagen Schaden. Diese Schadensanalyse müsste wahrscheinlich in der Form überhaupt erst mal aufgestellt werden, dass man da mit ein paar goldenen Behauptungen daherkommt und sagt, hier, warum fördert ihr das nicht, das sind wir, wenden volkswirtschaftlichen Schaden ab. Wäre...
Wäre gut.
Könntest du...
Würde ich unterschreiben, ja.
Würdest du unterschreiben. Jetzt sind wir aber am Ende, oder? Ich denke auch. Das war jetzt auch üppig und ausführlich und umfangreich, so wie es hier auch immer erfragt wird. Nicht wahr? Also, die Hörer sagen mir ja immer nur, es kann euch nicht lang genug sein. Mir ist es jetzt allerdings lang genug gewesen. Dir auch. Du musst jetzt wieder auch auf die Security-Veranstaltungen, die wir so noch gar nicht erwähnt haben, die gerade stattfindet, hier in Berlin, die PH-neutral, auch so eine sehr ganz verschworenen Treffen, wo aber auch immer ganz ordentlich gefeiert wird, deswegen... Es mag Leute geben, die das nur feiern, aber ich habe gehört, es werden auch tolle Vorträge gehalten.
Ja, es gibt auch Talks, ja, stimmt schon.
Es gibt auch Talks. Trotzdem habe ich sowieso immer den Eindruck, dass diese Security-Szene doch zu feiern versteht.
Ist ja auch schön so.
Hoffen wir mal, dass es so bleibt, dass es auch noch genug zu feiern gibt. Gut, vielen Dank, Thorsten, für die ausführlichen Ausführungen und vielen Dank wieder an euch, die Hörer, die hier immer so spannend bis zum Ende durchhalten. Und ja, ich hoffe, das war noch euer Geschmack. Ich habe es schon angedroht. Jetzt wird wieder ein bisschen mehr produziert, damit hier der Sendeflow auch nicht abreißt. Und was es beim nächsten Mal gibt, werde ich wie immer nicht verraten. Lasst euch überraschen und viel Spaß. Und bis bald bei Chaos Radio Express.